you're about to learn how to create this
cool beatmaker application from scratch
using python and pygame
this is a great project for both
beginners and experienced developers
pete lemaster created this course first
pete will show off the project and then
he will teach you how to code the
project line by line check the
description for a link to the assets you
need plus the final code good luck with
this project and feel free to leave a
comment with anything you learn in this
tutorial alright so i'm super excited to
show you guys this project showcase this
is one of the coolest projects i've ever
built and i think you could really enjoy
building something similar as well so
the key features of this app include the
ability to be able to quickly create and
edit brand new beats
as well as the ability to modify the
speed at which your loop plays and the
total number of beats in that pattern
[Music]
the buttons on the bottom give you the
ability to quickly pause or resume
playing the beat or clear the entire
board out when you're ready to restart
[Music]
you can turn entire channels of
instruments off so that you can edit
certain parts of your beat while keeping
the whole thing playing
[Music]
then when you get something you really
like the save menu lets you save that
under a name of your choosing
that you can load it back in later and
revisit some of your favorite creations
this tool lets you create some really
unique sounds and i hope you enjoy the
project
so follow along with the tutorial grab
the code if you want to from the link in
the description below leave a comment
letting me know what additional features
you'd like to see in this kind of
project or what you'd like to see on the
channel in the future if you enjoy the
video be sure to leave a like on the
video and subscribe to the channel for
tons more great content now let's get
into the tutorial alright super excited
to bring you guys this tutorial but it
is a long one so let's get right into it
and i'll explain uh what we're doing as
we do it so step one is going to be
importing pi game if you're familiar
with the pip module then you can use pip
and do pip install game or if you have
an ide a good one like pycharm which i
use then you usually can do an import
statement like that and as long as it
recognizes your module name it'll take
care of the import for you
and then i would say because this is a
heavily music themed uh
application import the mixer right up
front so pygame dot mixer is kind of pie
games associated sound effects and uh
music handling tool so we're just going
to do that right in the beginning and
then we're going to do pygame.init to
kind of initialize it which we'll need
for fonts and using a lot of the
built-in functionality
okay so that's just how we're going to
start it and next let's set up our
screen and since this beat making
software if you think about it it's kind
of you want the same dimensions as uh
your actual screen so wider than it is
tall because we're anticipating the
beats kind of stretching across the
screen
so i used 1400 by 800 and i kind of like
that but you can play around with this
stylistically if you want to
and
i just define a few rgb colors right up
front because i know pretty much every
app i make i'm going to use black white
and some shade of gray uh maybe 50 of
them
along the way and so i just do like
black white gray and then when i add
other colors later in the project like
i'll for sure be using some like red and
maybe a gold in this project i'll add
them up here
but we don't need that right now so
let's keep going uh and then the next
thing we're just going to focus on
getting the screen created real quick
so it's pygame dot display
dot set mode
set mode and then in square brackets
just do width comma height there we go
and you could type those numbers
directly here you don't have to put them
in a variable
this is much better practice and if you
wanted to change it later it's a little
easier to track down
something else i like to do technically
this would be considered an optional
step but i always like to set the
caption
and i'm just calling this one beat maker
you can call it something else if you
want
and then i'm gonna set up a font right
here which i'll call label font because
it's gonna be a little bigger but i
always create a text right in the
beginning because as soon as you need
text in your game um you're really gonna
want to have this initialized already
otherwise you're just gonna have to come
back and do a step later so i say this
in almost every project but if you don't
wanna go and get a ttf file almost
everyone's computer and install of
pygame is gonna come with this one that
you see right here freesandsbold.ttf
that's like a built-in
so you can use that one if you just want
to follow along and you don't care too
much about style i went and grabbed a
free one off the internet that's just
called robotobold.ttf
you can see it right here in my
file structure so if you want to grab a
font for your project and make it your
own just drop that file right in there
and then call it just like this
okay and then the only other thing you
have to give it here is uh font size so
we'll give it 32.
and that's uh we're also going to do fps
so that's our frame rate and we're going
to set up a timer which is going to
control the speed of our game which for
a music based application is super
important so we'll do
timer equals
pygame.time.clock some people will call
this clock some people call it time some
people will just do this directly in the
game loop i don't like doing that but
make sure you have something along this
line
and let's go ahead and create our what i
call the main game loop so we go just
underneath this
and obviously there's going to be a lot
of stuff going on in between our kind of
our variable library and our main game
loop but just to get it
just to get it started we're going to do
this so we'll set this variable run
equal to true
and then we're going to set up a while
loop that's wall run and the first few
things you always do while run is
timer.tick at your frame rate so now
this is saying as long as run is true
we're going to execute this code 60
times per second so that's the purpose
of fps and since a lot of our
functionality is going to be move on to
the next beat every second every you
know half second whatever this
timer.tick is super important for this
app
um so frame rate you want to keep it at
60 if not if you use a different frame
rate for some reason just make sure that
when we get to the part of the math
later where we calculate how many beats
per minute that you use your frame rate
um in that math okay so then we're going
to do screen.fill
and we're going to make the background
black i think that looks pretty good
and let's go ahead and set up what's i
always call this um event handling but
it's basically just uh getting all of
the occurrences that are actually
happening on your computer
um so it's for event
in
pygame dot event dot get and this little
application here every code we put uh
all the code we put inside this for loop
is going to be checking all the keys on
the keyboard the movement of the mouse
uh any any other event that the computer
can process is going to be inside for
event in pygame.event.get
and the first one you want to set up
just so your game will run is if
event.type is equal to and then it's
pygame.quit just like this all caps
and if that's the case then we just want
run to be equal to false
and that's all we're going to do for now
but we're for sure going to be putting a
lot of functionality in there later
okay and then outside of this we want to
do pygame dot display
dot flip
and that kind of throws everything onto
the screen and then we'll do this last
one is just going to be
pygame.quit just like that so outside of
any other code
just on the off chance it gets to that
point okay so reformat the format so now
we should just get the shell of our
project uh and it closed right away
because
i said robot bold and the file is roboto
bold so
there you go um
alrighty there we go we've got our
outline and i think that looks pretty
sweet um but let's go ahead and now
let's start drawing stuff onto the board
so um we will get to sounds pretty early
in this
project and i will
kind of go over how those are used
because obviously sounds are super
important
but first i'm going to set up a function
that i'm going to call draw grid and
it's just going to kind of draw
all of the static things onto the screen
so i'm going to do that right below my
screen.phil
is i'm going to call it draw grid
and then then we're going to come up in
between like i said the variable library
and the main game loop and i'm going to
define this variable draw grid and we're
going to start building this out
together
excuse me okay so let's start
with draw grid and just kind of think of
the space that we're going to have in
this game so i'll start i'll call kind
of the left menu
left box and that's if you've ever seen
like a beat layout like that kind of app
that's where you have the instruments
and sometimes you have the ability to
like turn tracks on or off or adjust
volume of the specific instruments so
we'll create kind of a left menu i'll
call it left box and we'll put it on the
screen and we'll make it gray so that's
why i call that uh color in the
beginning
and then we'll start at the top left
corner so at the very corner and we'll
make it 200 wide and we'll make it the
full height of the screen so these are
the four arguments you give rectangles
x and y starting coordinate in the top
left of your box and then width and then
height
and then after that these are now
optional so this would uh just give you
enough right here let me see if i run it
it should work we get this left box
which looks fine but now if we
add one more argument we're going to say
how wide we want the edges to be which
is going to make it a hollow object so
it's going to have a width of 5 and i
think that looks better as a left menu
personal preference you can leave it uh
totally thick if you want
um
but then let's also add a bottom menu
which i'll call bottom box and we're
gonna
pi
game.draw.rect this is where we're gonna
put like our player controls like start
and stop the loop of the game so like
play pause i guess i say game you
understand it's an app um
but uh we're gonna put like play pause
and then also like save and load so the
options to save your b or load in a
previously saved beat
or adjust the speed or how many beats
are in your app total we'll put them in
this bottom box so we're going to call
that screen
gray
and then for this rectangle let's put at
the bottom and actually let's make it
just 200 high so height
minus 200 so that's going to be the
starting position
and then we'll make it for width the
full width of the screen and 200 high
and let's make this um hollow with five
as well and what you'll see if i do this
now we're going to have this
kind of weird rectangle maybe you like
that look maybe you don't i'm going to
take my left box and i'm deciding i'm
going to stop it 200 high as well so now
we won't have that like crisscross
overlap in the bottom i think that looks
pretty good
so we will move on
the next thing i want to do is i want to
start creating the beat so we are gonna
make it so that it's adjustable how many
um boxes are in here but just to start
we're gonna just set it up so we can get
something on the screen so what i'll say
is um i'm gonna create a
little empty variable here that i'll
call boxes
out just like that and
i'm going to create a little colors
library so colors equals
gray white gray
some of this stuff we're not going to
touch for a little while so um if you
don't want to follow a long line for
line i guess you can skip that for now
but we are going to come back to it uh
sorry gray white gray
so we're going to do those but now what
we want to do is thinking of a drum kit
the first three most important
instruments are hi-hat snare and kick so
what i'll start doing is um kind of
creating space for those so first thing
i'm going to do is i'm going to call it
hi-hat text and now we call that label
font that we have and it's label font
dot font
or sorry label font dot render we
already defined it as a font and then
you give it the text and for the hi-hat
we will just say hi-hat that should make
sense
and then the second one is like
anti-alias as a boolean it's always true
in my experience i don't actually know
i don't know a scenario where it
wouldn't be and then later when we have
the ability to turn a channel on or off
so you set up a beat and you want to
disable the hi-hat we'll make this um a
variable so we will be coming back to
this but for now i'm just going to make
it white to not over complicate the
early steps of it
and we're going to draw it on the screen
so screen dot blit
and
you give it what text you want so we
want hi-hat text to get drawn on the
screen and that needs an x and y
coordinate and i'm going to move it a
little bit down and a little bit right
from the top corner even though this is
our first one and so this should be all
we have to do to see
the text hi-hat so i think that looks
pretty good
um
and now let's go ahead and
do let's just basically take this exact
stuff
c
ctrl v and let's do snare and kick so
hi-hat text we'll do snare text next
snare
and
snare text and then what we'll do is
we'll move it down a hundred so i
believe we made the game 800 high the
bottom menu is 200 high and we're gonna
put a total of six instruments in here
so we're gonna do a hi-hat a snare a
kick drum
a crash cymbal and then we'll do like a
floor tom and we'll do a clap um those
are kind of the six most basic beats if
you want you can grab your own sound
board and we'll go over that a little
bit later
and make whatever sounds you want you
can make as many instruments as you want
i'm kind of giving you the backbone of
how to set it up though so that'll be
snare and hi-hat let's go ahead and do
the next two
which will be
uh we'll call it kick because it's a
kick drum but you can call it bass if
you want
um and uh what the heck we'll say bass
drum on the text that's probably what
people are more familiar with
and we'll say kick text okay
and let's do after kick let's do the
crash symbol um
and crash
and crash
text
and we're moving these down 100 for each
of them so 200 300 and we're just going
to have two more
so we have bass drum and crash and then
we are going to want to do the clap and
the floor tom so clap
and floor tom okay and so we'll go to 3
30 4 30 5 30. now let's just draw this
and
see okay so that looks pretty good i
think what would make sense is putting
lines in between them to uh to kind of
delineate those so um why don't we draw
those as well after this text we'll just
do four i
in range
and i think we want
six because there's six instruments so
for i in range six
and we'll do this pygame.draw.line
screen we'll make it gray so it blends
in with the edges
and we'll start it at zero
and then for height
we'll want it to be
i
times a hundred so i
times a hundred but since we don't want
the first one to be at the very top
because the box already uh starts at the
very top and for four loops it's gonna
start at zero
and that's gonna go to five that's just
kind of how for loops in python work
they're not edge inclusive for the
number six so it's going to do zero one
two three four five um but we want these
lines drawn at 100 200 300 400 500 and i
guess we don't technically need 600 but
it shouldn't affect anything um so
starting position we'll do i
uh we'll do 0
and i times 100 plus 100 i think that'd
be a little better
or you could just add one to range i
guess that doesn't matter all right and
then end position we'll want it to go um
let's see
to 200 right that's how wide we made
that menu
um and then we want the same
y-coordinate so it's a vertical line
let's copy that
and put that in here
all righty and since the edges of the
menu are five let's make these lines
five as well and let's see if that gives
us lines in between all of our
instruments
i did something stupid i don't know why
i have this square bracket in here you
do not need a square bracket if you are
drawing a line
so the line arguments are the screen the
color start position as an x and y two
coordinate tuple end position as a two
coordinate tuple and then line thickness
and let's see if five is a little too
thick
uh
that's okay let's see if it looks better
as three maybe since these aren't the
outer edges of our menu maybe that would
look better
yeah i'd like three more um you can do
whatever you want if you want thicker
make it thicker
um but that's good for me for now
and now what i think we want to do is we
want to start considering how this game
is going to work how this app is going
to work in terms of the beats so we're
going to have a variable that will set
right now in the beginning
beats
and we're just gonna make it equal to
eight that's a very simple basic setup
that we could do
but we need to use beats in this
in this app to check how many boxes we
need to draw for each instrument so to
do that we do for i
in range and then
beats and let's create a variable that i
will call instruments and we'll use this
a few times throughout just to check how
many
rows there are so i guess you could call
this variable rows if you want
i'm going to say instruments because
there's six different sounds that we
have in here and i'm also going to
instead of fry and range six i'm going
to say for iron range instruments
but the reason i'm doing that is because
we're creating a grid basically for iron
range beats and then uh for j
in range
and this is
instruments and so this is another way
hopefully if you have the interest in
creating this game so or app whatever
i'll say game probably throughout this
because the module is called pie game
and i do so many games um
but so
if you want to add more instruments
we're creating it now to where all
you'll really have to do is adjust how
thick each instrument should be
so you could make it to where it was a
function of that 600
vertical space that we have you could
give them each 50 instead of 100 and
then have 12 instruments totally up to
you but we're creating nested for loops
here so for ion range beats and then for
j in range instruments what we'll do is
we will say
that we're going to draw this rectangle
equal to pygame.draw.rect
and we'll put it on the screen and for
now i'm going to just make them gray as
well
and we are going to make the
let's see we want to make the thickness
of them
i'm trying to think here i don't want to
misspeak we want the
thickness of them to be
we want the starting position to be i so
that'll be our b that's going to be for
the x the starting position will be i
times
and then we will want
the total width that we have available
for beats which is the width of the
screen minus 200 so we have this width
of the screen minus 200. put it inside
parentheses like this and then we're
going to use something called floor
division
and we're going to floor divide by the
beats so
this floor division just makes sure that
it's an integer because um for x and y
pixel position um i guess it's not
exactly pixel position but um it has to
be an integer so like let's say this
right now would be 1200 divided by 8
because that's how many beats we have
this is going to start it at 1200
divided by 8 which is like 150
but if for some reason it was like not
an even division this would make sure
that it stays an integer
okay
and then we'll want to move it a little
bit to the right
initially so as always as i said with
for loops this is going to start with
zero but we don't want it to start at
zero so we'll add the first 200 to it
and then i guess it's a five thick
rectangle so we'll add the first 205 to
it
and this is just our x starting position
so this rectangle is going to take some
math so bear with me
for the y starting position it's a
little easier because we don't have a
top menu so it'll be j times a hundred
and here it's actually okay that starts
at zero we'll just do plus five um
because we're gonna give it a width of
five as a border
excuse me
so actually we don't need a
border on the top it can be right up
against the top and this one will be
okay as well right up against that menu
so we'll do just plus 200 and then j
times 100 and then for the actual
rectangle we will say
excuse me
for the actual width we want it to be
the again width minus 200 and this is
going to be really important to make it
to make it adjustable to where it works
for any number of beats because a big
function of our app is going to be that
it's adjustable in that front
so again just do the width minus 200
floor divided by the beats this will
always give you the largest possible
width but still make each box even and
then for the height since we have six
instruments
we could do it this way we could do
height
divided by instruments
divided by instruments
but it's not exactly height divided by
instruments because we have a 200
width 200 height
bottom menu so it would be height minus
200 divided by instruments and you
should really make this a floor division
as well
but because this is 800 and we know that
800 minus 200 is 600 and we have six
instruments this is effectively the same
thing as putting a 100 here so if you
want to just make the height 100 go
ahead and do that
if you understand what's going on and
you want to do this math because you
want to be scalable again then do that
by all means um okay so let's see what
we have to do here because this format
doesn't look quite right i think i just
need to close the parentheses
and i'm going to zoom out a little bit
here because this line is a run on so
let me just
copy that into a new row there we go
and let's make this a width of 5 and a
[Music]
rounded rectangle those will look good
statement founded
let's see why we're getting errors here
i probably just did something silly on
the formatting
oh i have too many close brackets all
right i'm not going crazy
sorry for a little bit of
troubleshooting it's just uh sometimes
you put one too many parentheses in
there so let's just double check real
quick for these rectangles because we're
doing some advanced math here but once
it's set up properly it's going to
immediately be scalable to the whole app
so
we are starting it at the
beat so if there's eight beats it's
going to start at 200 and then it's
going to calculate how much room it has
on the screen and it's going to
automatically update um to take as much
space as it can and then it'll do the
same thing based on how many instruments
and we're gonna make it a rounded
rectangle which is what this second five
is for and we're gonna make it five
thick so that it should be hollow
rectangle now let's see because we
should get eight beats fingers crossed
that's not bad
we get um we get eight
uh beats right now per instrument and
they fill the whole screen and that
looks pretty good right there so you can
see we're getting kind of the
rudimentary
shape of this
fleshed out which i think looks pretty
good
so let's see we'll come back and we'll
improve the style later i think what's
going to be important is we start taking
a look at how to get this kind of
functional because that's going to be
really satisfying
if we can start actually implementing
that
a little bit sooner rather than later so
what i think we want to do because
you'll remember at the beginning of this
i created this empty list for boxes well
as we go through and create all these
rectangles what we want to do
is add some information to this list
that i made called boxes because we need
to bring that information back from our
function so that we can check if these
things are getting clicked so what we're
going to do is we're going to every time
we call draw grid we're going to empty
out the boxes variable right here we're
going to make it empty and then we're
going to draw all of these rectangles
onto the screen and then we're going to
return some information in this list so
what i want it to be is you can kind of
think of it of it as a tuple
where inside the tuple one of the two
arguments is another tuple so if that's
too confusing for you think of it this
way we're returning a couple things
we're returning
the rectangle of each beat but then
we're also returning an x and y
coordinate for it so we're returning
what beat it is which is the i and then
we're also returning
what row it's in which is the j
and then we're actually returning the
full rectangle and the reason we're
doing that is because we're going to use
that for the collision detection to see
if it was clicked on
and then what we will do next is we will
just return
that boxes variable we just talked about
so where we called draw grid
let me reformat that just so it likes
how many spaces so when we call draw
grid down here we need to get boxes back
from it so let's go back down to our
game loop and where we get um
boxes is right here
okay and what we need to do is use that
boxes um
list to check and see if we clicked on
any of the boxes
so that's not too bad we just have to
add some new uh collision detection so
what we do is we come down into where we
have this if event dot type equals pi
game dot quit
and we do if event dot type equals and
then this one is going to be pi game dot
mouse button down which is what uh is if
you're
clicking the button down and haven't yet
released it so there's mouse button up
and mouse button down
in uh pygame and that's what we're gonna
start with
and we're gonna create a loop that's
going to iterate through the entire list
so we'll say for i in range and then the
length
of boxes and the reason we're making it
the length of boxes is that list which
also means actually in the very
beginning this is important thing
anytime you create a variable
even if it's one that you get from a
function if you're going to use it in
your main loop you need to have it
initialized somewhere or it's going to
say that it was referenced before it
existed so for i in range and then the
length of boxes and the reason for that
is every time we update the total beat
the total beats whether it goes from 8
to 12 to 16 to 20 whatever
that list is going to get significantly
longer or shorter and so this has to be
scalable to check that whole thing
so for iron range length of boxes if
boxes and here's where we have to be
very careful about the way that we
addressed each item in there so boxes at
i so that just means we're going through
the list of boxes that we defined and
we're checking each box at i
which is going to call up the whole
tuple so rectangle and then coordinates
and then we check 0. so that's
referencing the rectangle that we stored
in there and that's
so the reason we did that is because now
we can use pygame's built-in collide
rect function which is this super useful
uh
super useful built-in tool which checks
if an x and y coordinate which in this
case will be the mouse and it's checking
to see if it collided with a rectangle
so in this case if collide wrecked with
event dot pause so event dot pause is
the position at which the mouse was when
the mouse button down occurred so the
position that our mouse is in when we
click
and uh
if it collides with it so this is
already right here going to check if we
clicked on any of the rectangles that we
just defined so we're creating a really
powerful function
and we're going to say chords is equal
to boxes at i
and then 1. and the reason i'm doing
this is because it's a little bit easier
than referencing the x and y coordinates
as boxes one
zero and then boxes one one like that
this is just going to give me this
temporary variable called chords
which we're going to use right below
to track whether or not something has
been actively clicked okay so
let's go ahead and do that what we're
going to do
and here's where we're going to need to
create a new list
because we're going to take clicked at
chords and i guess actually
we have to be careful about this we put
the i and then j and j is what row it's
in so actually we're gonna want chords
one
and then chords zero and i think i
missed a box there we go
okay and we're going to want to set that
equal to
the opposite of whatever it was
so let's go ahead and create the clicked
list and the reason i say list is
because this is what's going to keep
track of what variables have actually
been uh of what beats have been selected
or not
so at the very beginning i'm going to
create this list and we're gonna do it
in such a way that we define what's
basically a full list of negative ones
so i'm choosing to make negative one
mean it's not currently active and one
means it is currently active
i think that's the easiest way to do it
and i think you'll see why in just a
second
so let's do it this way let's say
clicked and this is our list of what
beats are selected and what ones aren't
and we'll say clicked for
underscore and because when you're just
doing it right here uh you don't really
need a variable like i or something to
reference so we'll just do for
underscore in range beats
so this is going to create initially a
list that is
that size and so for underscore and
range beats
and then it is going to be that
for
underscore
in range instruments okay so this is
going to create a list as soon as the
game starts up that because beats
initially is eight and instruments is
six it'll be eight negative ones in one
list and then it'll be a list of six
rows of eight negative ones
so it creates this really useful array
essentially a list of lists that's going
to initially be all negative one
and the reason i'm doing it this way is
because then when you click on a box we
can set it equal to
negative one of itself so we'll multiply
it by negative one so if it's a one
it'll become negative one but if it's a
negative one it'll become a one and the
reason we're going to do it that way is
we can use that list to draw all of the
active um
screen all of the active rectangles so
if they're a one that means they've been
selected and they'll be green
um so this is a really versatile way of
setting that up but what it does mean is
that we'll have to pass the clicked list
into our draw grid so we'll just come up
here draw grid
and we'll pass in the clicked list
which is fine it's not like that's an
inconvenience um
and what we'll do is we'll come up and
we will say
now remember i said we're going to check
for each of these rectangles and we'll
adjust the color based on
whether or not they're active
so i'm going to add a few more colors
here
i'm going to say green is equal to r
g
b this is it's uh
just
all all the greens zero two five five
zero and actually they'll be playing for
now because we're just gonna make it if
it's active um then we will have it draw
green okay
and we need to make sure we're receiving
the argument clicked and sometimes
inside of your
function it's not a bad idea to use a
different variable name like i know i
used boxes but because we totally reset
it every time that's not really a
problem
but we're not overwriting clicked in the
draw function we're just using it
so what we'll do here is we'll come down
and say
do boxes equals
colors
okay so let's do this for i and range
beats and then for j and range
instruments let's add something down
here that's going to say if clicks at
and this is going to be again j then i
because the first item is going to be
what row it is and then i is going to be
what column it's in
and we'll say if it's equal to negative
one then we'll have our color that we're
currently using be gray because it's not
active but then what we'll say is else
and you could say l if
and you could check if clicks is equal
to uh negative one
but then we'll say um else color will be
equal to green okay
and now i'm actually going to keep this
one because this rectangle is
essentially the outline of the rectangle
and there's no reason to mess with that
exactly
other than i just want to put a few more
stylistic things in here so we don't
need this second one
well let's make the colorful one the
rectangle that we actually reference so
we'll leave this alone down here but
then what we'll do is we'll say okay on
the screen
at our color
and then we want this one to be uh solid
so if you want it to be a rounded
rectangle which i think would look good
um but you want it to be solid
then just make this argument to zero and
that'll make it solid okay
now let's see what else we can do since
we're in here i think maybe i'd like the
idea of
doing like a gold
just to upgrade our style a little bit
so since we're here and we just made a
green i'll also make a gold and
i pulled this rgb ahead of time 212 175
55
212 175 55.
if you have a color in mind that you'd
like to use just google rgb value and
then the name of your color and you'll
be able to select through everything on
the internet
finding rgbs is not hard
okay so now let's go ahead and just
essentially move this rectangle that we
just made that is a specific color let's
move this one inside of the parameters
of this outer rectangle so here's where
we'll scoot them around we'll move this
one down five and in five
and then we'll make it uh this width i
think minus 10 so we're basically
putting it inside the frame that we
built before
and we'll make it this height
um
minus 10 as well since we're putting
inside a frame that's 10 by 10.
all right and we'll leave this uh
let's make this one
maybe black
and let's put this gold frame kind of
inside of it so i'm doing kind of a
three-tiered effect and this is purely
for style so sorry if you didn't like
this detour but i think it really adds
to the look of the project um and what
we'll do is we'll make this gold one a
full a full five by five and then we'll
put a black like wire inside of it
so
let's just go ahead and load this up
before we do too much and lose sight of
the project but what you're seeing is
none of these have been clicked and so
what i have currently is a gold rim of
five
with a
smaller only two thickness black rim
around each of them but it gives its
really cool depth to it i think now
let's try clicking
okay we got an error
object must be wrecked style event i
totally agree let's take a look at what
we're doing here so we are passing in
the rectangle pygame.draw.rect
yep that should be right and then we're
returning boxes
boxes dot append that looks good
oh
silly mistake because i used collide
rect in this position but it needs to be
collide point because what we're
checking is if the rectangle at boxes i
zero
is colliding with our mouse click which
is just a point so this needs to be
collide point not collide wrecked
let's load it and try to click some now
okay so there we go we get hi-hat um
green which is pretty sweet and i can
select multiples and now can i turn them
back off
yes i can let's see if i can select them
kind of from all over
yeah so that's perfect that's the
functionality we want and now you're
probably um aware
that we do not yet have any sort of
movement across the board to actually
play the notes
if we've selected them and i promise
we're getting close to actually having
sound which is really the fun part of it
okay but uh what we need to do is we
need to do some math to essentially
calculate
how long should each beat be
and so what i'll do is i'll come down
here
and i'll create a variable
and i'll call it beat length
and what it's going to be equal to and
this is where i mentioned right at the
beginning if you used a different frame
rate then this needs to be adjusted a
little bit more whoops bpm so we haven't
created a variable yet called bpm but
that's going to be another part of this
game so we'll say beats per minute is
going to be 240 initially which is 4
beats per second which is pretty fast
but that's what we'll use right in the
beginning
and so that means the length of each
individual beat as our game is seeing it
is going to be 3 600 divided by bpm
if you have to think of it this way you
can think of it as your frames per
second times 60 because in each minute
um there's 60 seconds right and then
that's if you're using a frame rate of
60 that's 60 times 60 which is 3600
and then we're doing floor division to
make sure we get an integer
of how many beats per minute we want so
this is how many clicks per minute
essentially how many loops per minute
this while loop is running and so each
individual beat is going to be that
number divided by how many beats per
minute they're supposed to be
and so what we'll do is we'll say
um
if playing we'll do it that way so we'll
create a variable and for now we'll
always be playing so right in the
beginning we'll set playing equal to
true but later when we put pause
functionality in it'll be nice to have a
variable that controls whether or not
we're playing
and so we'll say
if playing
then what we'll do is we'll create a new
variable if active length so how long
has the beat that we're currently on
been active and so right when the game
starts up we'll initiate initialize that
one as a zero
and so active length is equal to zero
right when we start so if playing
while playing if active length is less
than beat length
then we want to just add one to active
length so we have this variable active
length where we track what beat we're
currently on
and we're just going to add one to it
every time that we're not at beat length
but then what we'll say is else and so
this means that the beat has just
reached how long it's supposed to be so
just for easy math if we said we wanted
60 beats per minute
once every second we should move to the
next beat so we'll say else
and then that would make active length
equal to
zero
and now we need to check if we're
at the very end of a cycle and we need
to go back to zero or if we can move on
so what we'll do
is we'll create another variable and
we'll call it active beat and we'll say
if active b is less than total beats
minus one so that means we're not yet at
the very end then we'll add one to
active beat
and it's given me a oops active beat not
active length
and it's giving me a red underline
because we haven't initialized that one
either so right in the beginning
we'll call active beat 1
and you don't really want to start with
zero because in even though in code
programming you pretty much always start
with zero for a beat it doesn't really
make sense to be at zero at any point
you're always on beat one two three four
one two three four okay so activebeat
we'll add one to it
and then we'll use this variable that's
just going to be an on off variable
beat changed and we'll set that equal to
true
and we're going to use that in just a
second to actually play the notes on
that beat so else then we'll just add uh
then oops
else meaning else
against this if statement if active b is
less than or equal to beats minus one
and so we'll say else because in theory
if the beat was on like 24 or 26 out of
30 but you decided to reduce the total
number of beats then it it wouldn't work
to just say you know else if active beat
is equal to beats we want to say else
covering any scenario meaning we're not
at the end of our loop
so this is saying we've gone too far set
active beat back equal to zero
but beat changed is still going to be
equal to true okay and so uh let's go
ahead and
i think that should be all we need to do
to get it moving let's go ahead and say
beat
changed equals
true right in the beginning
because technically as soon as the app
loads up you would want this
on
and now we have to do something with
that
active beat variable we want to actually
draw
something on the screen showing what
beat we're on
um
okay so what we'll do now is we will
just say
we want to pass in what beat we're on so
we're already
we're already using um
[Music]
let's see
yeah we're already using the clicked
variable from the outside world so we'll
just come down to clicked and we'll draw
active beat as well alright and i want
to use a new color for this one so that
it kind of pops out of uh pops out at us
and i'm gonna create like kind of a
vibrant um not exactly neon blue i'll
just call it blue because it'll be the
only thing in my app i'll make blue
but to get this color i'm doing uh it's
pretty much like a teal or an aqua it's
gonna be a lot of g and b so it's it's
like a neon blue but i'm just gonna call
it blue
anyways we come into our draw grid
function and underneath everything else
we're drawing let's draw this new thing
that i'm just going to call active and
it doesn't really matter it's just so
that i know what i'm drawing because by
the end of this app there's going to be
a lot of code all over the place so
um that's just for me i'm gonna put it
on the screen we're gonna make it blue
and then uh we need to start thinking
about this rectangle so it's basically a
moving rectangle that shows you what
beat you're on
and uh to do that we'll use the beat
variable that we're passing in
times and then
width
floor divided by 200
minus 200 sorry this bit should be
familiar to you by now
divided by beats so we're talking about
where we want to start that beat
variable is one two three four five six
seven eight so you think about it when
it's a one we want to start at 200 so
it's going to be one times this
and then plus 200 so we need to scooch
dude plus 200.
um and so this means actually this might
be 200 too far we'll have to see with
minus 200.
we'll see when we load it up um
because it may be designed to start from
zero
yeah i wonder if that would be a better
way to do it
i'm not worried about right now that's
something we can tweak later all right
and then um let's see the y starring
position let's have it start at the very
top of the screen and then go all the
way down to
um the bottom of the instruments so then
how wide do we want to be well this
one's easy it's just width
minus 200 and then floor divided by the
beats so that is just saying we want
this rectangle to be exactly one beat
wide
and then we will make it as tall as the
instruments times 100. so there's 600
high basically it's just a rectangle
that's going to be surrounding the
entire active beat
and those are the four arguments the
rectangle needs except i put the bracket
in the wrong spot
there we go and then let's make this we
certainly don't want this to be a solid
rectangle let's make it a rounded
rectangle of border width 5 and a
cornered radius of three
and let's just see
if we correctly have
a beat moving across the screen so i
actually think that's pretty sweet it's
it is starting in the right spot it is
going to the end and then immediately
goes back to the beginning um currently
it's not doing anything with different
sounds but that is the next step so
let's go ahead and finally the thing you
guys have been waiting for um finally
let's implement some sounds
okay
and
for this i'll say i have a folder
prepared called sounds and i have these
six wav files in here i also have
another folder in there with some more
wav files that i'll talk about later i
just wanted to show how you can switch
between kits
but we'll get to that way down the road
for now
to do
what i'm doing you'll need to get six
wave files of these sounds
i used a free online download that i'll
leave a link to hopefully i remember to
put in the video right here if not i'll
make sure there's a link to the website
in the comments below and hopefully i
talked about in the intro of this video
as well
tons of free
sound kits on there so you can download
one that works for you just to be able
to follow along with this or honestly
you can make the noises with your mouth
and record record them but you will want
to use wave files mp3s
have some issues with uh mixer and they
don't work as well in my experience
okay so just make sure you've got this
sounds folder and a clap a crash a
hi-hat a kick a snare and a tom if you
want to follow along directly
and
i'm just going to make this little area
that i'll say load in
sounds okay
now
we'll start with the hi-hat and we will
set that equal to
mixer so remember we called uh
pygame.mixer right in the beginning we
imported it now we're going to use it
and to do that we set up this
mixer.sound
um and then all we have to do is give it
the file it lives in so sounds and then
backslash and i just called it
hihat.wave okay
so just like this and we're gonna copy
that and we're gonna make six of them
here so we'll say hi hat
and then snare
snare
and then we'll call it kick and then
we'll call
crash
and then clap
and then tom
okay and then in the sounds
locations we'll do snare
hi-hat
kick make sure that your names match up
exactly to what the actual files say
over here
i always recommend uh if they don't
download as something pretty logical
consider renaming them to something
that's a little easier a little more
logical
okay but just like this and if you do
have a t or a special character that
looks like an escape character like a
backslash n for any reason just make
sure to do this double
backslash because this is basically what
you need to do to get a backslash
interpreted as a literal in your
string you don't have to worry about
that too much but if you do get anything
funky where it like thinks it's an
escape character
just do those double backslashes
and that should work for you
okay so now we're going to come down to
where we did draw grid
and we're going to put in something
that's going to use that beat changed
functionality
um and so every time the beat changes we
want to play the notes so do do do for
iron rings
i just want to make sure i put it in a
good spot
screens for iron range instruments draw
a line
down in here
boxes draw the grid
okay
so what we want to do is say if beat
changed
and then
so if the beat changed we'll call this
function play notes
and this is just going to
play the sounds that we just created
based on the beat changing and then
immediately we're going to set beat
changed equal to false so this is how
even though this code the outside code
this while loop runs 60 times every
second this loop only runs once per time
that the beat changes and that's how we
control total number of times that the
beat
that the sounds get played so
that's that
now let's go into let's go above draw
grid and let's define the play notes
function since the sounds are right here
so we'll say define
play notes
and this one's pretty easy it's just 4i
in range
and then the length of our clicked list
if clicked at i
and then the active beat so that's all
we have to check is if clicked at i
which is going to check each row so each
instrument in our clicked list
at the active beat if it's selected as a
one
then we're just going to
check what i is equal to and then play a
different sound based off of that so if
i is equal to 0 we want that sound that
we created just do hi hat dot play just
like that that's the whole thing you
have to do
and then we'll do control c
control v and even though this one is a
little bit um
you know monotonous i would say it's not
too bad and probably outside of putting
these sounds in a list
um and then referring to a specific like
item index of the list there's probably
not a faster way to do this
other than just
going through and making sure you've got
the order right for your stuff crash
and then clap
and then tom actually i'm not sure
that's how we drew it is it hi hat snare
kick crash clap and then tom i think
okay that is yeah
if i is equal to five then we'll do
tom.play
and
this right here what we just set up
super fast super easy is all you have to
do to get the uh sounds playing or it
should be
okay so
um let's go ahead and just load this in
and see if we can get just some sounds
i'll try this hi-hat
okay and i'm really hoping i left sound
on recording the computer here so
hopefully you can hear that hi-hat going
if you're following along hopefully
you're getting this now let's play it
okay
[Music]
all right maybe it's just me but i think
the fact that we're here already is
super cool
and uh
you can turn stuff on you can turn stuff
off
and try playing around with your
different sounds once you get to this
point
all right it's so addictive i could stay
right there forever once you get to that
point that's a really good time to check
that the sounds that you imported are
actually the sounds that you're hoping
to get because um
you can change those sounds down the
road for sure but uh that's kind of your
first way of knowing whether or not you
um have sounds that you're going to be
happy with going forward
okay so there is one thing that i would
like to do on the mixer and it's because
the default for your mixer the default
for that when you load it in from pygame
is it has a total of what's called eight
channels that it can play on so eight
total
sounds technically that could be ongoing
but some of those wave files like the
crash symbol actually take a couple
loops to finish so in theory you could
run into this problem where you run out
of
sounds and so it has to pick what sound
it should let you play because its
default is to only have eight the the
way to get around that is super easy you
just do pygame.mixer.set
num channels
and then i think general rule of thumb
is that the number of instruments if you
give them each three channels
there should be no issues here
regardless of how fast you start playing
unless you're up to like 600 beats per
minute
then maybe you need to beef this up
um but the reason the eight is the
default is because in general if like
you have a video game going and you have
more than eight sound effects at once
it's just chaos but like for a sound
board as long as you're picking sounds
that sound okay together um having a lot
more uh channels is okay so you could do
instruments times four if you really
wanted
instruments times three has worked fine
for me in the past so we're gonna go
with that okay
so
um that's pretty cool i think we're kind
of at the point we want to start adding
some player functionality to this so
like let's do play pause because that
should be an easy one and then we'll
start doing it to where you can add more
beats and you can add more beats per
minute or subtract beats per minute and
then we'll add the functionality to be
able to turn on or off a specific
channel and then we'll start looking at
uh the ability to save and load files
which is a it's a lot that we got going
ahead of us so
let's just soldier on if you are
enjoying this video i think you've made
it this far already let me just say
please leave a like on the video
subscribe to the channel it would mean a
ton to me i hope you've been enjoying
the content i try to roll out high
quality content like this all the time
and the support means a lot if you have
any questions about what you're seeing
or want to see something specific in the
future be sure to leave a comment
letting me know about it
without any further ado let's soldier on
okay
so
let's do a play pause button and we'll
just come down below
draw grid and we'll just add a rectangle
that we're going to draw right down here
i think it's easier than drawing it on
the
i think it's easier than drawing it in
the grid but if you disagree with me
that's fine just draw it wherever you
want so i'll say lower menu
buttons and i'm going to create a little
section in my code for this now
and i will just call this button the
play pause button and i will say
pygame.draw.rect i'll put it on the
screen and i will make it gray
because it's on a black background so
gray will look pretty good i'll move it
off from the left by 50 and then i'm
gonna
raise it up from the bottom by 150 so
it's still squarely within that menu
and they'll make it 200 wide and a
hundred tall and that should be a good
button looking object we'll make it
solid and i'll make it a rounded
rectangle which is kind of normal for
buttons
um
and i will just yeah let's do some text
too just let everybody know um so i'll
say play text and we will set it equal
to the label font dot render
and let's give it the text of play slash
pause
and let's make it true and let's make
the text white
and let's put it on the screen so screen
dot blit
play text and then let's put it inside
that button by a bit so 70 and then
height minus 130 so it should be pretty
close to dead on to the middle of the
middle of the button and now let's add a
little check to whether or not we're
playing or not so if we are playing then
we'll have play text 2 here
so let's do a new font i'll call it
medium font because it's not exactly
going to be small but we are going to
come up to where we defined our font the
first time and let's create a new font
medium font and it's going gonna be the
same
it's just gonna be smaller because i've
got this button that's gonna say play
slash pause on it
i'd like to say underneath it whether
we're paused or playing
so i don't want to be small i want to be
super easy to read but it shouldn't be
the feature of the button so i'll just
make it 24. we'll see how that looks and
maybe we play around with it later
okay but yeah so we'll say um all right
playing text equals medium font dot
render
and then it is going to say playing if
we are playing
playing
true and we'll make this one oop i'm
still inside the string anti-alias true
and let's get a new
shade of gray
in our um
in our kind of colors library up top
uh and in general the closer to black
your gray is the darker it's getting so
we have this regular gray
i'll say dark gray and it's going to be
just 50 50 50. so black is zero zero
zero that kind of light normal gray we
have is 128 128 128 so the lower the
numbers on your gray closer to black
higher numbers lighter just
neat little gray
tidbit for you okay
so
we'll say play text is equal to
playing if we are active and we'll say
that it is equal to
so we don't need if playing this is just
else now
um else it'll be equal to paused
alrighty
and let's see
let's put it on the screen and let's put
it underneath so we'll take this screen
dot blit control c
and right there and let's put it height
minus 1 3 let's put 30 pixels lower on
the screen so height minus 100 now to be
100 pixels off of the bottom of the
screen
and it'll say playing or pause but right
now
we're not actually handling whether or
not it's been clicked so
let's figure that out here we want to do
inside of our
mouse button clicking code let's add a
second section for click up so
um in general if you want something to
only happen once then it's usually a
better idea to do pygame dot mouse
button up
[Music]
because if you're holding the button
down then it could technically like do
it multiple times and you don't really
want to mess with that so we'll go to if
event dot type equals pi game dot mouse
button up
and we'll say if play pause
dot
and i'm not gonna get wrong this time
collide point
there we go collide point with event dot
pause
and
playing
so the reason we need the and playing is
because if it's if it is playing then we
need playing to be set equal to false
and actually what's probably a better
way of doing this is rather than and
playing there we'll do if playing in
here playing equals false
and then we'll say l if not playing and
the reason you don't just want to do
else here is because if it was playing
you would come through and then it would
be not playing and then we'd say else
and then it would see that it's not
playing and immediately set back equal
to playing so you need to do an l if if
you do it this way
um l if playing equals true and that
should do it so we already have the
active length like checker stops if
we're playing so let's see if our pause
button works
oh boy
play pause i don't think i updated the
text
okay hang on a second play text medium
font dot render ah right here this is
play text two not just play text there
we go
all right that looks sweet we've got
playing down there
i pause it you can see our blue
rectangle stops and then it keeps going
i think that's great okay so let's see
if i pause it and i set up a beat
and i'm just doing kind of a generic
rock beat and we'll end with a crash
pause it
and let's add some floor toms because
those are cool
pause okay sweet um so that's that's
awesome i think that's a great start i
think um maybe the next thing we should
do is make it to where you can add more
beats uh more beats and more bpms so
that's kind of
um
that's going to be kind of complicated
but just bear with me because i think
we've created a really useful backbone
for this project where actually
everything is going to scale really well
we just have to implement it and we have
to be careful about getting all the
details right
okay so let's go ahead next and i think
let's add the bpm stuff so
we have lower menu buttons we're in this
um
we're still in this section for sure
lower menu buttons and we'll do bpm
stuff here uh and i just find it helps
to split it up with those comments a
little bit
and so first thing we'll do is we'll
make a bpm rectangle
pygame.draw.rect
and we'll put it on the screen
correct
we'll put on the screen we'll make it
gray and we will use more or less the
same size rectangle so for this one
we'll make it 300 to get it 50 pixels
away from the last one but it'll still
be height minus 150 we'll still make it
200 wide and we'll still make it 100
high
and we will
still make it solid
no you know what because this one is not
a button let's make this one hollow this
one is just displaying how many beats
per minute and then the beat per minute
add and subtract buttons will be to the
right of it so let's make this one
hollow
and then add some text we'll call bpm
text
and that will be the label font now
no we better not do label font because
uh it's a lot of text actually so medium
font dot render and then we're gonna
spell out beats per
per
minute there we go
okay and let's put it on the screen true
white and then put it on the screen
screen dot blit
and this is going to be the bpm text
and then for position we don't want to
move this one in too much because beats
per minute is kind of long so we'll do
308 just to get in by a little bit but
we'll still do the height minus 130 just
like that
um and then what we'll do is we'll do a
second text that's actually going to
show
bpm text 2 and that's going to be the
label font because that can be big this
is going to show the actual beats per
minute so not just the text telling you
what it is so this will be label font
dot render and then um you could make
this a formatted string if you wanted to
if for some reason you wanted to add
anything other than the beats per minute
variable
um
i'll do it that way just to show it
could be done so in theory you could say
like
bpm colon and then bpm
if you wanted to
but i'm going to put this below the
beats per minute text
and again
true and we'll make it white
and let's put this on the screen screen
dot blit
bpm text two and let's put it
just underneath so what would make the
most sense probably 370
370 and then i'd say that height minus
100 maybe where we put the last second
line of text let's just see
how that works and let's check this out
so beats per minutes 240 i'm a little
surprised because i thought i was
drawing a rectangle there uh bpm rex
green gray 300 oh i did height minus
1500 we want height minus 150
yeah that looks a little better okay so
that's cool but we can't uh adjust it
yet um
can't pause it it's still i just think
what we've done so far is really cool so
sorry if i enjoy it this is like the
most fun project i've ever made
um okay so beats per minutes 240 but we
can't adjust it yet uh so that we're
able to do that let's go ahead and add
two more rectangles and this might not
seem like the easiest way to do it but i
actually think this is a pretty logical
uh way of doing it because in general
you're not adjusting beats per minute by
one at a time if you want to by all
means make these plus and minus ones i'm
going to make them plus and minus fives
because most of the time you see speed
beats per minute adjusted in increments
of 10 or occasionally five it's really
weird to see a song that's in like 137
beats per minute um it's much more
normal to have 120 240
so i'm just going to do it in plus minus
fives but you don't have to
just driving a motorcycle down the
street scared mill
okay bpm ad wrecked so this will be the
rectangle that will let you do plus five
and we'll say pygame.draw.rect we'll put
on screen we'll make it gray and this
time let's go a little bit to the right
so that last rectangle we made start at
300 and at 500 this one will just give
it a padding of 10
and then we'll put it at height minus
150 so the height of the top of the
rectangle and we'll just make this one
48.48 almost 50 50 to where it'll almost
these two rectangles will almost fill
the full height
but not quite i just think everything
looks a little better with some padding
around it and then we'll say bpm
sub
wrecked so this will be the button that
lets you subtract 5 from your beats per
minute and we'll do pygame.rect put it
on the screen make it gray
now this one um still at 510 we want at
the same height or we want at the same x
position but then we'll just do height
minus 100 and now since they're 4848 we
have a little bit of padding which will
be nice
as you'll see
when we load it in and i really want to
emphasize the style stuff you can do
whatever you want um with yours so if
you don't like the way mine looks or you
think it would look better uh in some
other way tweak it change how big fonts
are change your font
change your colors do do whatever you
want i'm just trying to give you the
functionality
uh okay so then what we'll do
is we'll create some add text
and this will be kind of nice because we
can use it on the beats per minute um
buttons and uh i guess in theory we'll
want to do just plus and minus ones for
the uh beats text so i forget what i was
about to say
okay add text is medium font
dot render because these are smaller
buttons so we can't afford to make them
huge and we'll do plus 5 for add text
true and white
and then sub text subtext nice that's a
thing
medium font dot render
and then in
string variable minus five
true and white and then let's do screen
dot blit for add text and let's put that
a little inside so 520 because the
button starts at 510 and then height uh
minus 140 so a little bit down so we're
giving it kind of a bracket of 10. 10
on the top and the left and we'll see
how that looks
it will do about the same thing for the
subtext so 520 and then height minus 90.
90. there we go
all right and we haven't had any
functionality so nothing happens if you
click it right now but let's see if that
looks good
yep okay so next thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna make it to where when you
click that button it actually adjusts
your bpm by plus or minus five
and that is not hard to do so we'll come
down into our mouse button up code where
we check um if the
uh
if the
play pause button gets while that was
hard for me to get out if the play pause
button gets pressed and we'll do if add
bpm add wrecked
dot collide point whoop
collide point
event dot pause
and so if that's the case then we just
want bpm plus equal five and then we'll
do an l if
bpm
subrect dot collide point event dot
pause
bpm minus equals five and actually we
can make our codes slightly more
optimized by making these all lifts
because in theory we know
that these buttons are not in the same
spot so we can save our code a little
bit of time by not bothering to check if
you click these other buttons if you
already clicked this button in this loop
because you're not going to be doing
both
uh and that's super simple that should
be all we have to do so let's go ahead
and check it out
let's see
i'll go ahead and put some sound in here
[Music]
and let's see if we can make it faster
yeah it's giving me anxiety now
okay but hopefully if you're following
along uh that's really cool that should
um be like super encouraging you just
made this happen
you are a programming king good work
keep it up
maybe i'm just talking myself but i
think you're enjoying it too
all right so the next thing we have to
do is we have to add beats and that is
going to be a little bit trickier
because we have to obviously update our
clicked and update our
total grid so we have a few lists that
have to get updated if we change how
many beats are in the song but
we can start basically with the um bpm
stuff that we just made so we'll say
beats stuff so
you know yes there's a little more
programming we have to do on the back
end but at least to get the rectangles
drawn
it is not going to be too bad at all so
we have beats rect
beats text
beats text
beats text 2 even because it really is
it's a second
um it's the second version of the bpm
something that you should have control
over we want them to be able to add and
subtract
so we'll say add text to
subtext to add text to subtext two and
we'll do one beat at a time
because technically you could have any
um
you could have any time signature you
could do nine beats total if you really
want to so we'll say beats in
loop
this time we are at we are currently our
right limit i guess is 560 right so
would it make the most sense to start
this at 600 probably so we'll do 600 and
then everything else i think is fine
this will be 608
670
and then this one should probably now be
8 10 8 10
8 20 8 20.
and we haven't had anything for
operational code yet so nothing happens
when we click these buttons but that
looks good let's move the text to the
right
because this is not as long so beats in
loop can be like 6 18
and this can be like 680 i think that'll
look good
yeah that looks better all right moving
on
the actual functionality that we need
when we click these buttons is a little
bit more complicated
um
so
let's take a look at what we need to do
when we collide with the points all
right so
we'll come down to these two
bpm add rect and subrect
and we need to do an l if beats add rect
collide point in l if beats
and initially we can kind of use the
same code because we're we are going to
take the beats variable that already
existed and we're going to add one and
subtract one
um but that is not enough right there
because we have to
we have to add a full row a full empty
row to our our grid if it was um
and make sure i say this right a full
empty row to our grid if we add a beat
and we need to remove the last row in
our grid if we subtract a beat so what
we need to do is say for i
in range
length
of
clicked
length of clicked there we go
we need to
remove oh wait this is the plus one so i
am
gonna steal this
there we go um and so this means we've
just pressed beats minus one
and what we need to do is we need to say
for i in range length of clicked clicked
at i so this is going through each row
of our clicked
list and we are going to click i
dot pop which is the python list
function for removal and we're going to
pop the minus one which means the last
character on the end so there's this way
you can address this is the index inside
that list and if you do a negative it's
counting back from the end of your list
so pop minus one this is going to go
through and remove the last item in our
gr in our list for the clicked list
and then
for the beats plus one we go through and
we do essentially the same thing
so actually i was on the right track
already um except instead of pop minus
one it's actually kind of fun it's
append and it's still a minus one
because minus one means not selected so
uh this
is now
everything so i think this is going to
make let's see fingers crossed
so we hit plus one and now we have nine
on the screen how cool is that and the
entire screen updates every time we add
one so now we can go ahead and
do 12 beats
i'm gonna pause it while i set this up
so bass snare bass bass snare bass snare
crash
yeah
and this i mean you can play around with
it already if you want but this can keep
going you can make this thing 48 right
here you will notice it's a little bit
tedious to fill in 48 beats but um
it it's
we set it up in a really smart way so
that this is completely adjustable based
on how many apps uh how many beats you
want in your loop so
i mean awesome job guys we are
just cruising along here let's add some
more functionality because this is going
really well let's add the ability to
turn off a channel so that you can edit
it without it affecting your live loop
um and turn it on and off just like that
so
to do that we are going to come up and
we are going to create some instrument
rectangles so essentially they are just
let's go down here underneath the beat
stuff and we'll say
instrument rex and i'm just doing this
so that we can click on the channels
and we'll say instrument rex
equals
and then a empty list and then for i in
range
instruments and i'm trying to make it so
that if you copy this code and then
later on you want to add some more
channels
i'm trying to make it as
scalable to that automatically as
possible
so we'll make this little rect equal to
pygame.rect.rect and you'll notice what
i'm doing now is i'm defining a
rectangle but i'm not drawing it on the
screen because we don't need it on the
screen
and for this one it's a little different
we're just defining a rectangle and so
this one needs two tuples instead of
a list of four characteristics it needs
an x and y starting position and so x
and y starting position will always be
0 and then i times 100 so
just just as we go through the list it's
going down 100 at a time but it's
staying all the way on the left
and then the width for all of these was
200 and they're all 100 high
and then we're going to do instrument
rex dot append
and
that rectangle okay so what we're doing
is every loop we're coming through and
we're creating this list
of rectangles for those buttons but
we're doing that so that we can come
down in our um
in our
collision detection inside of our mouse
button up clicking
and we can check if any instrument uh
rectangle was clicked super easily so to
do that we'll say l
we will say 4
i
in
range
length of
instrument rectangles okay
so this is going to check every
instrument rectangle that we define
and what we're going to say is if
r
if
instrument wrecks sorry i try to give my
variable
names long descriptive names so that as
you guys are following along
it's pretty clear what everything is but
these are maybe longer
than you would want to use in an optimal
project
but so we're gonna check if every
rectangle in there um was clicked we'll
say if instrument rex dot collide point
with event
dot position
then what we'll do now is we're going to
create a new list and i'll call it
active list
and we will set whatever instrument was
clicked so whatever is at active list
i
times equals minus one and so we're
going to use the same kind of logic we
had in our clicked list
for our active list but this is going to
be a little simpler because it's not
really an array it doesn't need to be a
list of lists
so we'll go down to clicked and right
underneath clicked i will make another
list called active list you could call
it active channels active instruments
whatever
and in the beginning i'm going to set
them all equal to true because i
actually think our default will be
having all of your instruments on
and it's just going to be one
for underscore in range of
instruments
okay and this is just going to give us a
list of six ones saying all the channels
initially will be on but if you click on
a channel it'll turn off and where we'll
update that is we'll go into our draw
grid function
and we'll pass in that active list so
we'll say actives
down here and we'll give them the active
list
and now due to actives so you remember
this colors uh gray white gray that i
made before i would like the text of
each instrument to be the color of its
active list position so essentially if
you click on it
then i want it to be a one meaning it's
active or a negative one which is
actually going to be gray because
remember a negative one is the last item
in a list so i just think that's a
clever way to do now hi-hat text is
going to be colors zero
um
wait wait a second
colors no active
actives
zero okay so let me be uh super
thorough to explain this item because
now it's a little confusing we're
referencing an index item of a list in a
list
but actives zero is telling us whether
or not we currently want hi-hat to be
active right
so um is this is going to be a one or a
negative one depending on whether or not
hi-hat is on and so if it's a one we
want to be white if it's a negative one
we want to be gray
so now we do we just do this exact
colors logic that we did here
for all six instruments and we just make
sure we update their index location and
as soon as i do this i will load it up
and show you what we're doing so two two
two three
four and five
and again if you need extra
clarification on anything we do in this
uh just let me know about in the
comments i'll get back to you as soon as
i can
so if i click hi-hat you can see it
turns gray which is great um
if i click snare it turns gray bass drum
i can
sort of make these inactive
but what does that mean for the actual
code
and so we need to come into our play
notes function because it's going to
impact it in here as well
so what we need is if clicked i is equal
to active beat and we need to check and
active list
at i
is equal to
positive one okay so this is all we have
to do now because when we check and see
oh it's time to play the hi-hat because
in my beat that i've set up it's a one
well we checked and saw that actually
hi-hat is turned off so it is not time
to play the hi-hat
and it'll work that way for all of them
so that's all we have to do there but
it's still going to look bright green on
the screen and so it might be a little
confusing why it's not playing maybe you
didn't notice the text was dark gray so
let's also in the grid
i think i like this idea
we'll go up to
in here where we check the colors so if
it's not selected it should be that
light gray that basic gray already but
then what we'll do is inside of this
else statement we'll check if active's
at
j now it's actually j is the beat for
this loop so
um hopefully that's not confusing for
you but maybe it is um this is checking
what instrument so if our active
instrument
is positive then the color should be
green
there we go
there we go okay but if the
actives
j actually we can just do an else here
so
we checked
to see if it was a one
if not then we'll want our color to be
equal to dark gray dark gray there we go
so now let me explain what we just did
but make sure that you're following
along and hopefully i didn't confuse you
too much
so let's say you have a hi-hat playing
every beat in your loop
and then you want to
add some bass
but then you want to kind of see what it
sounds like without the hi-hat it
okay you can turn just that channel off
and you see the squares go dark gray but
what's cool is that still gives you the
ability to edit it so you could still be
working on your beat um and then turn it
on so like let's say i want to add some
crash and some clap i don't know what
these are gonna sound like this could be
wacky but now i could turn all this
stuff back on at any time
and then you get this whole kind of
funky b actually that doesn't sound too
bad and i'm going to turn the bass and
the floor toms off
and we have individual channel control
so that's really cool that's another
cool feature that like a standard drum
pad would be able to do for you so
okay we have play pause we have beats
per minute we have beats in the loop we
have all of the
um ability to add beats add speed um
add a hi-hat uh or turn off individual
channels things like that we've looked
at how to load in the music so i think
we're getting to the point where we need
to work with an external file to be able
to load and save um specific beats that
we've created
so
we're going to do that next but i need a
quick water break
okay so the next thing i want to do to
our app here is i would like to add a
save menu and a load menu
and i'm going to put them on two
different menus because i think that uh
kind of helps separate out functionality
but you could probably put all this on
one um that's just up to you
but uh let's get into it
okay so let's start by just drawing the
rectangles because from there we'll
start building out how this actually
needs to work so let's come down to
where we draw everything and we have so
many rectangles and beats and instrument
rectangles all getting drawn
next thing we'll do is
save and load stuff
okay
and we can pretty much use the same
rectangles that we've been using in the
whole menu because there's nothing wrong
with them
they look just fine
so we will say save button equals
and that'll be pygame.draw.rec
screen
gray and now we need to make sure we
keep moving them to the right so that'll
be
this one we'll put at 900.
and we'll
put height minus 150 and actually i
think it'd look cool maybe
if uh
these were one over the other so height
minus 150
and then 200 wide and we'll only make it
48 high kind of like the plus and minus
buttons because we'll do save above load
and we'll just see how that looks
so zero and five and then we'll do load
button just underneath it
so i'm going to copy the same button
equals control v and then minus 100 and
everything else is the same
yeah those buttons look pretty good
let's put text on them now
uh so i'll grab actually i think these
maybe can be label font i think they'll
be all right so we'll say save text
equals and it'll be label font dot
render should be pro at this by now
and we'll just say save b
and we'll make it true and we'll make it
white
gotta spell things right
true and white and i will take this
whole thing save text and we'll do the
same thing for load
load text
load beat
true and white and then we need to put
them on the screen so screen dot blit
screen dot blit and this one we want to
save text and we would like to put it
just a little inside the button so 920
and height minus 140 and that should
give us a nice
fairly square in the center of our
button kind of thing
and then we will do screen.blit load
text uh and then this can be 920 as well
and then minus
90.
and let's see again we're not pressing
those buttons yet but yeah the text
looks good you can play around the
spacing if you want they're on the
buttons so what more do you want from me
you guys
okay save beat load beat
and the reason i put them one over
another is i want to add another button
once we're done with this that's clear
board so like let's say you've filled in
like this whole board with squares and
you totally regret it and you just want
to scrap it and start over rather than
closing the program and then opening it
back up we'll just do a clear board
functionality so
um actually
that's going to be easier than the save
and load so why don't we just do that
right now we'll do uh like clear board
because that's gonna be like three lines
of code
so clear board we're gonna add
clear button
and it's gonna be
same button actually i'm just gonna copy
all these because it's just going to
have text as well pygame.draw.rect
screen
[Music]
and then
we'll want this 900 it's 200 wide so
we'll want it at like 11.50
does that make sense 1150
and height and this one can be the full
100 high i would think
and then this text will have it say
clear board okay clear board
and then we'll put it at
1160 and height minus 130 let's try that
1160
height minus 130 and this will be clear
text and clear text
all right so let's see if that looks
okay
i would like to move that down some
height minus
120 that'll look better
yep okay let's do the clear board real
quick because clear is way easier than
save and load save and load is going to
be a lot of dealing with external files
and i think just this is going to be a
little faster so let's go ahead and
check if
the clear button collides with the point
so we'll come down to our lifts because
it fits nicely in here and we'll say l
if clear button
dot collide point event dot pause so if
you've hit the clear button
then actually what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna set the clicked list
equal to what it is in the very
beginning so
you know we check how many instruments
and how many beats and we just set them
all equal to minus one well we can just
come under our clear button and do the
exact same thing
and so that is really it all right let's
check that out real quick so we've got a
whole bunch of high hats and some there
we go just a random terrible button
you're like oh what have i done clear
the board you're empty you're free there
you go
okay so we had clear functionality
that's sweet good job
now let's do the save and load um and i
want to do it where save and load will
actually kind of stop playing the music
and it will
kind of make it to where you can't click
the rest of these buttons
so uh what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
create two new variables called save
menu and load menu and we're going to
use those kind of similar to playing
to see like if something is currently
true so up by beat changed i'm going to
say save menu and it'll be equal to
false when the game starts and so will
load menu they'll both be equal to false
right in the beginning
but one thing we are going to do in the
beginning as well and you'll want to do
this you'll want to drop an empty text
file into your um
pygame uh project so if you need to make
one in the outside world and drop it in
that's fine but if you have a decent ide
you can do new file and then just call
it like
my beats or whatever.txt
i already have one called savedbeats.txt
and to
say like hey we're going to be using
this inside of this
program
then you want to start early in your
function and just do file equals open
and then
save beats or whatever the name of your
text file is dot txt
and then comma
and then since in the very beginning we
want to read the data in so let's say
you close down your session and two days
later you come back and you want to do a
new session
um
you want to
uh
read all of the information that's in
there currently and we'll do it kind of
like a csv or comma separated values
file where each line in the file will be
all the information we need for one beat
so it's going to be how many beats are
in it
how many bpms what name did we give it
and then the clicked list of that guy
so we'll do for line in file
the file that you have
and we'll make a list called
savedbeats.append
and then that line okay
and saved beats doesn't yet exist so
right above file let's just do save
beats is an empty list to start
okay and since right now we don't have
any saved beats uh it's just going to be
an empty variable until we do save some
stuff later on but
this is how you open up and store the
data from a file initially
alrighty so let's go ahead and use save
menu and load menu now if we come down
to
our buttons
and the first thing we're going to do is
check to see if you've clicked on a
button so if you click on save menu or
you click on load menu and one thing
that we're going to add to all of the
mouse button
logic so far
is we're going to say if mouse button up
and not save menu and not load menu
because technically everything is going
to be there
even after we load in a new screen
that's going to be covering it up so we
just want to make it to where you don't
have to worry about clicking the buttons
on the underneath after we've created a
new menu
so
all of that's great
and then kind of the counter to this is
once we have save menu or load menu up
we need to make sure the buttons in
there can be pressed and we'll do that
by adding a new line that's going to be
and
uh so pi game mouse button up and save
menu or and
and load menu and we'll do that a little
bit later okay
so let's get down to business
and not save menu in that load menu and
then we'll want some lifts in here
checking if save menu or load menu were
clicked so l if
save menu
save button
dot collide point
with event
dot position
then we want save menu to be equal to
true
and then we'll say l if
load menu
dot collide
point
at event dot pause
then we want
load menu
to be equal to true and we don't want to
run this code just yet because it'll
disable all of our buttons and we won't
be able to do anything but close it
um
but this is going to make it to where
our save menu and our load menu do get
opened up
and when we're loading in i think yeah
we'll just leave it like that for now
um
so
what i mean when i say we need to kind
of take this exact same code but
we're going to need to do some different
stuff with it
is
we're going to use this menu so we'll
say l if now because we don't want to
run this if save menu and load menu are
false but we'll say l if event dot type
pi game mouse button up and we'll just
say we're going to create an exit button
so we'll say if exit
button
dot collide point
event dot position and we'll use an exit
button on both the save menu and the
load menu just to get out of it so even
before we actually set up the
functionality of uh saving and loading
we just want to have the ability to
enter a menu and then exit a menu okay
and we'll just make sure that
playing is equal to true
when you get out of the menu just on the
off chance it pauses um it shouldn't
because we don't have it set up that way
but
just now we have it okay
so uh we're not doing anything with save
menu or load menu yet but we want to so
let's come up to our other functions
where we draw stuff screen.fill boxes
yeah and so we want to do
before even the box is getting drawn so
screen dot fill is the only thing that's
happened yet and we'll say if save menu
then we'll do a function called draw
save menu
and then we'll say
same thing if load
menu
then we'll say draw
load menu
and just so i don't forget we want to
make sure we get the exit button back
from both of these
exit
button
equals
draw load menu draw save menu okay
and uh that's really what we have to do
we have to think about this in order of
what's the bare minimum we have to do to
get these menus going um and then we can
start adding the actual functionality to
them okay
so let's take a look at uh it doesn't
really matter which one we start with
they'll be sort of similar in format so
we'll come down just below our draw grid
and we'll do draw save menu first so
draw
def
boy i'm having some trouble typing def
draw save
menu
okay
and we just have to make sure we return
an exit button before anything else
let's just make sure we don't forget
that
okay
and let's honestly let's just put that
on the screen first um so we'll do
exit button
um and let's not call it exit button
because we use that so many places let's
do exit btn just to separate it out and
we'll say exit btn is going to be equal
to that pie game.draw.rect
and we'll put on the screen we'll make
it gray because all of our buttons are
gray
and for
x position
let's put it at
very far over to the right so width
minus 200
let's do width minus 200
and height minus 100
and then for width let's make one
excuse me 180 so it doesn't quite touch
the right side
in 90 so it doesn't quite touch the
bottom
and then we'll make it a solid rectangle
with um rounded rectangle edges of five
just like we always do
and let's make some exit text here
that's going to say close menu
in label font so label font dot render
and it'll just say close
and
to do
true
and white let's do that
and then screen dot blit
screen dot split
exit
text
and we want it what do we want for the
coordinates for this guy
we'll put it width minus 160
so we want inside that button width
minus 160
and height
minus
height minus seventy that'll do a little
bit of
cushion there
and let's see i'm basically gonna copy
this entire thing for draw load menu
just so initially
draw
load menu so initially we have the
ability to just test out opening up
those two windows um but we do actually
you'll see
this is gonna be a little weird um
if we don't do another step so let's say
we're saving the beat okay we're in some
menu now
uh but we haven't done anything that's
going to make it feel like a menu so
um oh bool has no object
load menu dot collide point
this what did i do
exit button
oh i did load menu instead of load
button you goofy goof pete there you go
okay all righty
um
one thing i wanted to say we want to
draw a rectangle that's basically the
full screen so
pygame.draw.rect put it on the screen
make it black um
and make it the size of the entire
rectangle so start at 0 0 make it the
full width and height and no rounding no
edges
we want to be solid and make that the
first thing you draw on your menu and do
it for both so what you'll see now if i
hit save beat
well you'll see nothing because i did
something wrong let's take a look
oh
so it's not working because i put these
way too early you want these
menus to kind of be the last thing that
you draw so after everything else is
getting drawn
so after the clear button after
everything we want the drawing of these
menus if the menus are selected
and the reason for that is this code is
drawing things in this specific order so
the last thing it's doing is right at
the bottom checking if you have a menu
active or not so we have this ability
now to go into the load menu and the
save menu
just like that
okay and to kind of illustrate uh what
else we could do is we could say while
we're in these menus we can pause the
stuff
so the buttons aren't doing anything but
that music is still playing and if that
bothers you then super easy thing to do
would just be set playing equal to false
uh while the menus are active i actually
think it might make sense to have it
still active while um while we're in
there because if you're saving a beat
maybe you want to be hearing it to think
of what a good name for it would be
but okay this is good um the important
thing was that we were
getting those menus to work because now
those menus are blank slates that we can
open up and do our work in
so we can kind of stop messing with the
main loop which is getting pretty gummed
up so we'll start by just working in
these menus
and so to start with the draw saved menu
um
let's do draw save because it's a little
bit simpler drawing uh the loading menu
we have to kind of sort through
everything that's been saved and that
can take a little while so let's start
here we have the full rectangle
let's call this menu text and we'll just
kind of tell them what they're
doing on the screen so we'll say render
and we'll say save menu
enter a name for current
beat
okay
and we'll make it
true as always white as always
screen dot blit as always and let's put
the menu text
menu text
and let's pick a good spot for it about
440
and let's
see what that looks like
so save menu
enter a name for current beat that looks
pretty good i'm happy with that
so that's cool but we haven't we haven't
really done anything yet we've just got
that going on so next let's put some uh
let's put a button down before we worry
too much about the typing
um
space
let's put a save button on the screen so
we'll call it saving button because
there's already a save button so that's
maybe a little confusing but that's what
we're doing
okay pie game
pie game dot
draw dot rect and we're putting it on
the screen
and we're going to make it gray because
that's what we do with buttons and we'll
put it sort of in we're making it fray
we'll put it pretty much in the middle
of the screen so we'll do width
um
yeah width divided by 2 4 divided by 2
and then we'll do minus 200 so this will
be a real wide one we'll put it height
times
0.75 so we'll put it at 3 4 of the way
down the screen but we'll make it 400
wide and 100 tall because it's a big
button it's kind of the whole purpose of
being on the screen so we'll make it a
bigger button saving button and then
we'll do saving oops skating
saving text saving txt
and that will be label font dot render
label font dot render
and this will have the text be
save beat
and true
and white
and screen dot blitz saving text
and we want to put it
at about the same spot so
around
width divided by 2
maybe minus
50 this time because let's say it's a
hundred wide maybe i'm guessing and that
could be a good spot for it
and then we'll do height
times 0.75
and then we'll do plus uh
10
20 30. we'll put it in the middle of a
button 30.
um and that should give us a big old
button that says save on the savings
screen save beat yeah we want to move
that to the left a little bit
um
okay but we've got the beat the button
on there which is important and let's
move it
minus 70. i don't know i'm winging it
here
save beat that's pretty good
okay
uh so we've got the save beat and now um
one thing we're already returning the
exit button but we also want to return
the saving button um because we are
going to check if we collide with it in
the outside world so go down to where
you are
drawing your save menu and we'll do exit
button and
saving button and we'll use that later
to check whether or not we're saving the
beat
and now we'll want to pass in a few
things into this actually we're going to
want to check um the current beat name
because we're going to be typing in to
to save a name and then we're going to
want to check whether or not we're
actively typing
so
yeah it's not happy because those are
not yet variables
but we'll come up here and we're going
to make these new variables we're going
to make beat name and it'll just be an
empty string initially
and we'll make a new variable
typing which initially will be false and
then if we come up into our draw save
menu
then you'll see we now are passing in
beat name
and we're passing in the typing variable
and so to do this we're going to make a
new like entry box in the middle of the
screen
um and so we'll call it doesn't really
matter where we put it we'll call it the
entry rectangle so entry rect
and that'll be equal to pygame.draw.rect
and we'll put it on the screen and we'll
make it dark gray
and we will
uh let's just make it regular gray
because we'll use dark gray to signify
whether or not it's been clicked
okay so screen gray and then let's just
put it at 400
200 600 200 all right
so um it'll be the middle 600 pixels of
the screen 200 will get down from the
top by a little bit
and we'll make this sucker
by five so there'll just be this big
empty rectangle
and then we're gonna have the entry text
which is going to be uh basically
telling us what we've currently typed in
so label font.render
f string
of
beat
name
and
there we go true and white and we're
going to want to blit that
screen
dot blit the entry text and we're going
to want to put it right
inside that
variable that rectangle
okay and we need to return the entry
rectangle as well because we need to be
able to click on it and determine
whether or not we're actively typing or
not
and i believe that's all we'll need okay
so now let's go back down to where we
call that and make sure that we're
passing the entry rectangle back so
unresolved draw save menu did i
accidentally change the name of the draw
save menu beat name
and typing i'm sure i put another
oh yeah i put a semicolon in there such
a silly goose okay
entry rectangle
all right so let's do something with
these buttons i'll show you what it
looks like now you should be running it
on your own as well
and you see we've got this nice
rectangle in the middle where while
we're typing a beat name it'll load in
so let's go ahead and close
and let's do something with all these
buttons that we've got so now we have to
go down
and check what to do if all these
different things get clicked okay so we
are in
this section now this l if type pie game
mouse button up
where we have the exit buttons um
obviously to kind of reset everything
and we'll clear out the beat name so if
you were halfway through typing a beat
name and then you close the menu we'll
set it equal to empty and if you were
typing we'll set that back equal to
false because now you're obviously not
typing
all right and so let's start taking a
look at the things that we just defined
and uh in the in the menu and what we
want them to do so if you click the
entry rectangle then what or yeah if you
click on that rectangle then what we
want to do is basically change what
state of typing you have
so if entry rect
collide point event dot pause
pause
then we will say if typing
then type being equals false and then
we'll say l if
not typing so again this is where if you
just did an else you'd get this tricky
little thing where it comes in and says
oh if typing
typing equals false else but then the
else is checking if not typing and so
you'll just get this kind of sticky
situation so do an l if not typing
set typing equal to true
and we're just going to use um if typing
to handle a new type of
event so we'll come down into the
level of this like l if
so this l if and we'll say if event dot
type
equals and now we'll use a new type
which is pygame.txt input so that's
you've hit a key that has a text value
and the typing variable is true and so
this is how we'll handle not modifying
the beat name if you're not actively
typing
and then we'll say plus equals event dot
text because when you hit a text key a p
or an underscore an apostrophe or an m
the
value of the actual key that you hit as
it appears in a string is event dot text
okay
and then we'll say if event dot type
equals
pi game dot key e down and we'll check
if so key down is another type of
event
and we're using this to check if the
specific key that was pressed if event
dot key is equal to pi game dot
k underscore backspace so we want to
check if the backspace key was pressed
and the length of beat name is greater
than zero and this is an important step
because if the beat name is already
empty we don't want to try to remove
text from the variable that's keeping
track of the beat name it's already zero
characters
but what we have to do here because
there's not really an easy way to just
pop a character out of a string you have
to redefine it and so what we'll do is
we'll say beat name now is equal to the
current beat name and we use this range
of characters and so
leaving
leaving there as a no character before
this colon means start from the very
beginning and then a minus one means go
to
the character that is right before the
end of the character so this is
basically just a way of grabbing the
entire string up to the most recent
character
and so just with these two um we have
added functionality that's going to let
us remove and actually we want another
um and typing condition there
so now the entry rectangle should
determine whether or not we are um
actively typing or not and then the uh
the
text input and key down characters here
should change whether or not we're able
to do anything so we haven't handled the
actual save button yet we'll we will do
that next but now let's go ahead and
see how our menu works so save i'll
click in here and now i should be able
to type pete backspace backspace
backspace i'm going to type p is cool
now if i click this rectangle again
and i keep typing yep it's not doing
anything which is good that's what i
want but we haven't visually shown that
anyway
so let's go back into the save menu
save menu
and let's add like a dark gray insert
rectangle that says when it's time to
type um so or maybe a light gray would
make more sense but i'm going to do with
a dark gray because it's my tutorial all
right and so what i'll do is i'll say
before the
entry rect so where was that entry
racked here
yep
ctrl c i will say if
typing and then i'm going to put this
rectangle in here and it doesn't need a
name because i'm just using it um
to signify whether or not we're typing
and i'll say dark gray
and i will just make it
solid
in the same footprint and that's okay
because we're drawing it first so your
edge will still show up
and that should now be a good way to
signify so save beat
there we go we're typing pete
is cool okay
and if i click off of it okay well now
i'm not typing anymore and now i am and
i can do backspace and whatever and if i
close it exits and that's great
so
let's go ahead and handle the save
button and i kind of been putting it off
because
working with external files and saving
data to a text file is just a few extra
steps
and um and we have to kind of choose
what data to store and in the right
format and it's a it's a process so
let's get into it
because it's very important to the
functionality of this obviously being
able to save your favorite beats and
come back and use them later is a huge
value add to this kind of thing so
we'll come down here where we have our
entry rectangle and we'll add a new one
and we can really do these as lifts as
well
and so we'll say l if
saving button be very careful because
now we have a save button and a saving
button and we'll say collide point with
event dot pause
and if so then what we want to do is
kind of again file equals open
and our
savedbeats.txt file but this time
remember in the very beginning we read
from it to store data into that
variable
now we're going to do a
w and that means we're going to write to
it
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take that saved beats
save beats list that we made in the very
beginning and we're going to append some
data to it and if you remember i know it
was a little while ago
we said what we're going to be adding we
always want to start this with a new
line um because
if you don't then
anytime you save then you could
potentially be um saving on to the same
file and then the way we're parsing data
with the like per line storing it as one
entry in our list would get messed up so
we'll do it this way we'll do name
colon and then
space
and then we'll do string brackets
beat name so this is what you entered
beat underscore name okay
and then we'll do comma
and then we'll do
beats colon space curly brackets
beats
and do pay attention to the format that
you save it with because later we're
gonna kind of have to reverse engineer
this for our loading menu
so we're saving everything we would need
we're saving everything we would need to
be able to
recall this later we're saving the
clicked list we're saving how many beats
and beats per minute and then a name
that we gave it to to be able to save it
and so we're going to add this
as one item to our saved beats list
which means it's going to be the format
of a saved beat
and then what we'll do
is we'll say for i in range
length
of
saved beats
there we go
we want to do file dot write a string
of saved beats and this is what you have
to do because to write to a text file it
has to be a string so you have to make a
string conversion of each entry of your
saved beats list
and then to get it to save outside of
that for loop we're going to do file dot
close and that will close up the text
file with all the new data and then we
will go ahead and close the menu so now
save menu equals false
capital f false
because if you've just saved your b
there's really no reason to uh stay in
there and then we'll set typing equal to
false because that's kind of our default
and we'll clear out the beat name
variable so this is kind of saying
you've accomplished what you're here to
do
and now even though we don't have a way
of loading it back in you can see we
have an empty saved beats text file
right now let's go ahead and make one so
let's make a beat
i'll just make it the kind of like
generic rock beat i've been doing
sweet i'm gonna save beat and i'm gonna
call it
generic rock beat and i'm gonna hit save
beat and let's see
okay it's a good sign it didn't close
anything let's go ahead now and look at
our text file so you can get an idea for
how we're saving it
okay this is pretty cool
it's name generic rock beat beats 8 bpm
240 and then selected and this is the
list you can tell it's got all of the
hi-hat so that's what this first one is
and they're all on which is why they're
all ones and then this is the snare i
believe and you can see it's just the
threes so like one two three four one
two three four for the snare the kick
drum is one and then one one
so you can tell this is a list of
everything we would need to do to
recreate that beat so once we've saved
it we could clear it out we could close
it and move on with our lives
and uh
and that's really cool but
we have no way of loading it in yet so
that brings us to the load menu and i
have been putting this off because um it
is probably the trickiest one we have to
take all of that information we stuffed
in a text file and we have to reverse
engineer it out of a text file so let's
get started me complaining about it
isn't going to make it go any faster so
let's go into the draw load menu
function
i'll take a sip of water here
okay so we have the
back rectangle and we have the exit
button
which is a good way to start i'm going
to kind of poach the menu text from up
here and the saving text
and
kind of steal those because we're going
to just reuse them for a
menu text which now will say load menu
and select
a
beat
to
load
in now we'll just say load that's fine
they know what they're doing and then
instead of saving button we will say
loading button and
instead of saving text loading text
and that will say
load beat and that will say loading text
but the positions are probably good
and then um obviously in addition to
exit button and uh everything we are
going to need to do the
loading button as well
and i think we will want to
also return a delete button probably
because maybe you've put too many in
here now so let's just also make a
delete
btn that'll be good
and so we have a loading button
let's go ahead and and loading text
let's go ahead and make a delete button
delete btn
and where should we put this
delete button pygame.draw.rect
wrecked and screen and gray you know how
it be
and let's put this one on the screen
roughly
so we'll do width divided by two to get
the middle point and we'll do minus 400
so
kind of scooch it
left from there
it's minus two
minus four hundred that'll be the x
starting position we'll put it a little
bit lower so height times
what should we do 0.9 i don't know
getting a little delirious is a long
tutorial
okay we'll make it solid we'll make it
round rectangle and we will just see
where that is how that looks and uh
kind of go from there i don't know why i
would put this at point nine it should
be at the same height as the load button
but let's see so if this is starting at
width -200 and this one starts at minus
400
it's 200 that's gonna touch our loading
button let's try making this 500
i don't know i'm playing around now i'm
in uncharted waters
alright so we need to add some text we
need to delete text
and put that on our delete button and
that'll be label font dot render and
this time we will do delete beat for the
text
delete
beat
okay and then it should be
white
and first we need to do true for the
anti-alias white come on pete you know
this and then screen dot blitz and then
delete text
delete
text
okay and
um for location on this we just want to
kind of steal the x and y starting
position from up here
ctrl c
delete text
and scooch it a little bit inside so
let's see with now minus 500 instead of
500 let's do like
485
and then height times
oh
0.75 my friend okay
uh and then plus 10. let's
let's just see what we've done i think
this is hideous but let's do the load
menu load be oh that's not the worst
thing in the world is it okay
um that looks alright let's go ahead and
scoot delete beat down a little bit what
did we do for the other one plus 30
we'll do plus 30 again
okay and now we need to oh if exit
button
tuple has no attribute
collide point well who's a tuple here
exit button pygame.draw.rect
i don't fully understand why i got that
error load beat
close
uh oh
so tuple object has no attribute collide
point i understand what that means
but exit button
is right here draw load menu exit button
loading button delete button oh maybe
it's because we haven't told the loading
button function it's getting a few
things yet so hang on we're returning
exit button loading button delete button
come down to where you call those
menus and it's exit
loading
button and delete
button and now the close button should
work unless i am crazy
and i am not all right good job well i
might be but let's move on
um okay so back in the loading menu we
need to kind of set up a area that is
going to be where we display the info
from our loaded beats so load menu
select a beat to load we say that we put
the text on the screen but we do not
show currently um like the area where
the beats might be
so let's draw um i think like kind of a
holding pen like a
outer rectangle where all the data is
going to be displayed
so let's just do
pygame.draw.rect for that
let me think what the right way to do
this would be
yeah let's draw a holding pen if you
will and let's say pie game.draw.rect
and let's put it on the screen
and let's make it gray
and let's give it
190 100 plus
let's start at 190 200 let's just see
how that looks and let's make it
i don't know a thousand high
and
600 wide i don't know i i'm kind of
conflicted here cause i want this to be
i think like a outline but i don't know
if it makes more sense to have it like
as a solid rectangle for displaying the
loaded beats
so whatever i did that's hideous let's
fix this
okay let's fix this rectangle i think
190 90
we can make it a thousand high it'll be
fine
600 should be fine
five and five is probably okay i think
what we'll want to do load beat i think
what we want to do is just move load and
delete lower down because i do like the
idea of being able to show quite a few
different beats
so maybe instead of .75 on these we do
try like 0.9
or close to it let's scoot these down
and do like point i don't know eight
seven
um let's try that point eight seven
point eight seven
point eight seven plus thirty let's take
a look at that load beat
there we go that's not bad actually um
kind of that entry rectangle and so
let's go ahead and call that something
let's call that um
i don't know
beats rectangle
loaded rectangle we'll call it loaded
rectangle
rec
dangle
yep and i think we'll want to return
that too because uh if you clicked in
there somewhere you'd probably be
selecting a beat okay
so let's come down to our function where
we grab stuff back delete button
and we'll say
load rectangle down there
okay
or loaded it doesn't really matter
all right and uh let's see about
actually parsing data in this draw load
menu so
um we have to kind of check
on what
index has been selected so first you
know what we should do we have a text
file with one saved beat let's go and
make a second one
okay so let's just make this stupid
it's not the it's not the worst thing in
the world but i'll just call this tom
and clap
save the beat and let's go ahead and
close that and look at our text file
so now you see we've got these two
and let's say we have the load menu and
we want to parse through the data um of
those two and show them on the screen we
want to show how many beats they have we
want to show their name and everything
so what we need to do
is we need to start checking on um
like
how do we get the specific stuff inside
of those and so let's just dive into it
there's no easy way of doing this
so here's what we do we start and we say
for
beat
in
range
length of
saved beats so remember saved beats is a
list where each item in the list is a
long string that has one of those saved
beats in it
so for beat
in range length of saved beats and let's
just set up our rectangle to display 10.
so if beat is less than 10 meaning we'll
start at zero
okay beat clicked is going to be equal
to an empty list and we just kind of
have to set up some
stuff to parse through this it's a
really long string so row text is going
to be equal to
medium font dot render and we're just
going to show what row
this is so uh it'll be f and then
that's a format string and they'll be
beat plus one because it's going to
start at zero but again i don't really
think we should say anything is the
zeroth beat it'll be the first beat
and we'll say true and white and we'll
put that on the screen so screen dot
blit
and we'll give it the row text
and we'll put it at 200 100
plus
the beat
200 100 plus the beat times 50. so
that's how we'll make this um work for
every for 10 because the rectangle's
like 600 high
all right so that should be all we have
to do to put the row text on there
but we have to start getting some
indexes so this is where if you're
familiar with string manipulation in
python you'll be a little bit ahead of
the curve because a lot of what you're
about to see might not make a ton of
sense
unless you're familiar with strings so
we need to figure out where to start the
name and so we'll say uh saved
beats so that is the list of all the
beats that we've saved and then beats so
we're calling our specific string and
then we need to find the index value so
this is where in that string we first
see this specific substring so the index
of name colon space and you'll see
why i was so particular when we set up
that right
that right instruction to the list
because we have to replicate that in
reverse to tear it apart
okay and then because there are six
characters in this string
n-a-m-e colon in space we're going to
add a 6 right there and then the name
index end
end
is going to be equal to
saved beats at beat
dot index
and then
it's going to be so this now is going to
be where the next thing in our string uh
is added in and so if you think about it
i'll actually pull up the text file here
name ends when we get to colon space
beats so uh we kind of have to do this
thing where we check where each piece of
it starts and stops by doing this so
beats just like that is going to be
where we want to end it and then name
text
the actual text for each of these is
going to be equal to and we'll make this
medium font so that we can put it on
screen dot render
and then the text for it is going to be
saved beats
from
at beat so that tells you which item to
use and then we need to do what's going
to be from name index start and then
colon name index end and so this might
seem a little confusing but we just what
we just did is say okay take the list of
all the saved beats choose it for the
specific one we're looking at and then
from where this name text stops so
basically the next character after this
name colon space appears
all the way up until this colon space
beats appears that is the actual text
that is the saved name for this uh beat
and then we want to be true and then
white and then uh we're putting it on
the screen so screen dot blit
and it's gonna be the name text and it's
going to be comma and then 240
and then 100 plus
beat times 50.
that's not the times there we go
b times 50. and so this is just where
we're putting the row text as well
and let's go ahead and just start there
because
i think if you're familiar with how this
works when we go to the load menu you
can see we have generic rock beat tom
and clap and those are the first and
second names that's really great so
that's awesome what we have to do now
is we have to figure out how to parse
the rest of the data because that is
just one of the items and that's great
for showing them on the screen but we
also need to figure out how to get the
beats per minute and the selected list
out of there so this is going to be a
little tricky bear with me and again if
you get lost in the specifics be sure to
slow the video down re-watch the parts
that confuse you and feel free to ask
your questions in the comments below
alright so now what we're going to do is
we're going to say
if
0 is less than or equal to index and
we're going to get to this index
variable we're about to make in just a
second
um so if it's greater than zero and less
than the length of saved beats
i'm typing all over the place
shift tab get out of here there we go
um
and less than the length of our saved
beats file so this means that you
currently have a beat selected we're
going to use index as a way of selecting
a specific beat
so this i'm going to put it up here so
we don't forget to pass it in
but we are going to select by clicking
on one of those beat names we're going
to select which one we want to load in
and that's going to be the index
variable and then based on what's been
selected we're going to need to do some
additional work so we're going to need
to figure out where the index
end for the beats is and that's going to
be equal to saved beats
at our specific beat so that's why we
still want it to be
wait a second length save beats and
we want to add a second condition here
and b is equal to
index so uh that's why we're putting
this inside of our for loop still
because this will check and see if while
we're getting the names for each beat
this will check and see if we've also
actively selected a beat and so and beat
is equal to index
all right then what we'll do is we'll
say
at that dot index so just like before
and now the next one starts at
colon space oop make sure you're a
string in a string variable colon space
bpm
because this is where the beats per
minute
variable starts and so that makes the
loaded beats
loaded beats which is a new variable
equal to
integer of
saved beats
dot
beat
trying to be very careful here because
we have to do this uh kind of double
indexing thing again so it's not save
beats dot b it's save beats at beat and
then we have to do from
name index end
plus 8
to
beats index end
so the reason it starts at name index
end is because uh um or name index n
plus eight characters is because this is
going to start with the colon
and um it's going to end
eight characters later which is when the
actual beats value starts and that's why
we put an int in here to convert it to a
number so what it's doing is we're
indexing from this character
to this character
and we're turning into a number so even
though it looks like 8 is a number this
is actually inside of a string so it's
just another string character until we
do that int but now we're getting back
the loaded beats which is great
and we have to do basically the exact
same thing for the bpms so the bpm index
end
bpm
index end which is a new variable as
well
is going to be equal to saved beats at
beat
and then it's going to be dot index and
this one is going to be now when colon
space
selected
i didn't put it in quotes again
here we go
when that appears that's going to be the
index that's going to say okay this is
the end of the bpm section
selected and that's going to make the
loaded bpms
equal to pretty much the same thing as
this loaded beats just with different
index values so i'll grab that so this
one is going to go from the
not from the name index end but from the
beats index end and it's not going to be
plus 8 it's going to be plus 6
i think i typed an 8 again and then
this one is going to go until bpm index
end
beats index and
interesting oh it's just beat index and
there we go
okay and so now we have the bpms the
beats and the name of it and what we
don't have is just the trickiest part
which is going to be the selected list
so
we have to now
loaded
clicks right because we called it
clicked in the outside world so loaded
clicks and i'm going to differentiate it
at loaded clicks as a string is going to
be equal to saved beats
at beat
and then we already actually have all
the info we need for the rest of this
one
it's going to be
bpm index end
but then this one is going to be plus 14
okay and i'm about to explain why it's
plus 14 and it's gonna go essentially to
the end minus three characters and the
reason for that is we need to do what's
called splitting the strings out so if
you say this is where it started so 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 characters before we get to the
first one or minus one in our list
and then if you go to the very end we
have
a space and then two end brackets at the
very end which is why it goes to -3
that's going to give us a string of all
of our values
now we have to split that string into a
list and to do that we're going to use
the built-in split function but we have
to tell them what to separate each
list item on so
we're going to split it
we go down to loaded
clicks and we're going to call this now
a row
rows because we have to split this twice
right it's currently
just one long string we need to split it
into a list of strings and then we have
to split each string into
actual ones and negative ones
so to do that we create this
intermediate list which will be loaded
clicks rows and set equal to list
and then inside of this we do
loaded
clicks string
and then dot split is the built-in
function to split a long string into a
list
and it's going to be
open bracket like that and then
comma and then space and then close
bracket or backwards close bracket comma
space open bracket and the reason for
this is again if we look at the text
file
what splits up in between each entry
each item in that selected list is a
closed bracket and that comma and then a
space and then open bracket and so
that's what's going to split each item
into its own list item in here
okay
so now
we get to do uh some more complicated
stuff so bear with me and once we're
through this maybe really take a look at
what each line is doing and think about
what it's doing and um really try to
make sense of it and then ask me if you
still have questions after that but so
for row in range
length of
the loaded clicks rows list that we just
made
so we're setting up a for loop to go
through there and we're going to say
if
loaded
clicks
here we go
if loaded clicks row
item
so item is just checking um
we don't want this to be row we want
this to be item
uh i'm getting ahead of myself that we
do want that to be row and we want to
say
loaded
clicks
row
is equal to and i'm just going to create
another intermediate variable just to
get my head straight because there's a
lot of words going on so we'll say load
clicks row is equal to
loaded
clicks
rows
plural
at
that specific row um and then what we're
gonna do is we're going to split that
row item split
out and we're gonna do it based on
a comma and then a space and the reason
i add the space is because when you do a
split it's going to give each
thing in between those its own item in
the list but it's going to get rid of
this text that was in the string
so we do it this way
and then that's going to split it up and
make a new list and that we're going to
store that in loaded clicks row
and then what we're going to do
is go through and say for
item because they're not yet integers
in range and it'll be the length of
the loaded clicks row that we just made
okay
and what we're going to do is we're
going to check if loaded clicks
row singular
at item
is equal to and we'll check if it's
equal to the string of 1 or the string
of negative one and the reason we're
doing this is once this has been sorted
once we don't want to run it again so
we'll say or if loaded clicks item is
equal to negative one because in theory
those are the only two things the items
should ever be equal to
and we don't need another if we just
need an or
so if it's equal to a string value of
one or a string value of minus one then
what we do is we say that loaded clicks
row
item
is equal to the integer value of
loaded clicks row
at item
and the reason we're doing this
if check is because once it's become an
integer this won't execute anymore so we
don't have to execute this anymore
because everything is already an integer
all right so that's why we do that and
then we come out of the if and we say
that we want to track what beat was uh
what what loaded in beat
um
is
let me say this correctly we want to
make a list of the clicked values of
what was loaded in so if we have this
loaded
clicked
list that basically reflects the outside
clicked world then we want to
make sure that we are appending at the
right time so we'll come back up here to
where we did this beat clicked list
and we will append each list in here so
we'll say
let me make sure i get my indentation
right beat clicked
dot append
and we're going to add loaded clicks row
each time we do another row and then
we'll say loaded click is equal to
beat clicked there we go
and we'll want to as well as the loaded
rectangle we'll want to return the
loaded clicked
but we actually we need to return the
loaded clicked and we need to return the
beats and the bpm so let's make another
variable out here and let's call it
loaded
info and let's make it a list and so
it'll have loaded beats in it
it'll have
loaded bpm in it and it'll have loaded
click in it all right but what we need
to do because right now there's a
reasonable scenario where nothing has
been selected yet and so
these might not exist because right now
the only place we define them is if
something's been selected if we've set
that index value so what we want to do
in the very beginning is just initialize
them like you would in the beginning of
your program but we'll do it inside the
function so loaded clicked equals zero
loaded
beats equals zero
load clicked is an empty list not zero
but you get the idea and loaded bpm is
equal to zero
okay so we need to do those three things
and then we pass it all back in loaded
info and so we'll pass that back instead
um so
this was i know
one of the more complicated things we've
done manipulating strings like this is a
little bit tricky but we actually did
some really advanced stuff here so if
you're a beginner
you should congratulate yourself if you
just managed to follow along and
understand most of what we just did
because that's some pretty tricky string
work
now we get to kind of go down to the
event handling and actually set up what
we want each of these things to do so we
come down here to the area that's
outside of checking
um that it's not the save menu and load
menu so it's this second part
and we will
come on down do do do do if saving
button collide point
beat length file okay so
if mouse button is up
entry rectangle what we want to do now
is we want to say
l if and what do we say loaded rectangle
so if loaded rectangle
was clicked then we want the index to be
equal to
and we're going to use that event
position at 1 which is the y position
minus 100
and then we are going to floor divide
that by 50 and this will give us a value
1 through 10 telling us like where on
the uh
where on the y axis we just clicked and
we'll use that index for what the active
beat should be so let's come back up in
loaded menu and use that index to draw
something that's going to indicate the
actively selected beat
okay so back in our loaded menu
we're passing the index in let me make
sure we're actually passing it in though
load menu draw load menu here we go we
want to make sure we pass that in and
actually we don't uh we don't initialize
it in the beginning do we so let's call
it up here we'll just say
index is initially equal to 100
that way it's not selected
okay and draw load menu we'll say okay
if load menu zero zero
but we want to use the index to draw a
rectangle on the screen
if it's in our range so underneath load
rectangle i will say if
the index
if zero is less than or equal to the
index and it's less than the length of
our saved beats list so this is checking
that we have one it's less than the
length of our list then we will
pygame.draw.rect
the screen
we will make it let's do a light gray so
this will be the last gray i add i swear
and we'll make it 190 and then we'll
have it start at 100 plus
index times 50.
and
we will have it 1000 wide and 50 tall so
light gray let's go ahead and define
that up top
and this again it's moving the opposite
direction of our basic gray so light
gray
and this will be like a
like a
170 170 170.
okay and now i'm hoping when we do the
load menu load beat
broke something too many values to
unpack expected four because i don't
think i told it to expect loaded info
coming back yet so let's see
uh
[Music]
load menu loaded info and
load rectangle
loaded info correct
there we go
loaded info all right uh so now let's
open up loaded beat uh generic rock beat
oh
string has no yeah i sure did mean index
i sure did
so let's go check that out
and which one did i put in x for
index
index in next there we go
alrighty let's try that again load beat
hey we got a light gray rectangle if i
click the top one if i click second one
if i click third one it goes away great
because there's no beat there
and i click those that's sweet but we
are not able to delete things yet and
we're not able to load things in yet so
let's keep working on the buttons
all right back to our event handling
down here and there are maybe ways i
could have set this up differently but i
kind of did them as we got to each event
so
let's come down here and say
all right we have all these lifts lifts
loaded rectangle
let's do l if
delete button dot collide point
with event dot position
and then
if we deleted something then what we
want to do is actually not too bad it's
if index so pretty much that same thing
if index is between zero
so index needs to be greater than or
equal to zero and index needs to be less
than the length of
saved beats
and i can say less than because
the length of saved beats is always
going to be one greater than the largest
index value of it so if there are three
values in there their indexes are 0 1
and 2.
so
what we'll do
is we will just save beats dot pop
whatever was at the index and that'll
let us
delete an entry that one's pretty easy
um we'll highlight the functionality of
a few of these at the same time
once we get them working okay
so next let's do the loading button
because that one's kind of tricky and we
will do l if loading
button
dot collide point
event dot pause that part's easy the
next part is
familiar if 0
less than or equals to index
less than
length of
saved
beats
then we are going to set a few of our
variables equal to the information that
we pull in so beats is going to be equal
to the loaded info that we passed back
which i believe we just called loaded
info yep
loaded info
uh at zero so the first thing was beats
loaded info zero and then the second
thing was bpm
and so that'll be loaded
info at
one
and then the third was clicked which
will be loaded
info at
2
and we will set the index back equal to
100 so that's like a irrelevant number
and then we will set load menu equal to
false just like we did when
um the save button was pressed because
your work is kind of done now
um and we will
that should be all we have to do i
believe
so let's go ahead and check it out now
if we have got all of the functionality
on that load button
i think the close button was working i
think uh we're able to click in there so
right now looking at our screen we have
nothing going on there's nothing loaded
in if i load that generic rock beat in
well i hit load beat nothing happened
uh it did close
load be let's try tom nclap
okay
close i can feel it but no cigar so
what's going on
okay i think the reason the loading
button is not working is we need we just
did l if loaded rectangle earlier it
needs to be lift loaded rectangle dot
collide point
with event dot position so i'm really
amazed the indexing and highlighting of
the rectangles was working without this
but
that should let us load it in so let's
go ahead and check load beat generic
rock beat load beat
there we go and that's really sweet now
let's try clearing the board that's also
awesome let's see if deleting one works
so let's get rid of tom and clap because
this is kind of stupid anyways so let's
go ahead and see if we can delete it and
it looks like we got rid of it now let's
do something that uses more beats and
more beats per minute so let's do
um 24 is that like a logical thing and
let's make this a higher number like 480
and see if that works
okay so we're up much higher now and
let's just kind of put i'm going to turn
it off just so it's not too much noise
for you guys so that's eight
that's 12
16
20 and then for these last four we'll do
crashes
all right and then let's do
bass snare actually we're going to want
to spread these out a little bit
because it's sort of twice as fast as a
normal rock beat so we'll do bass bass
snare
take a pause and then we'll do bass bass
snare take pause bass bass snare and
then we'll do clap
clap clap at the end
and we'll do floor toms at the end let's
see what these sound like
now we'll add some four times because
we're hardcore
all right so i'm going to save this beat
and i'm just going to call it uh
interesting clear board save beat
so that's not working now
uh we need to figure out why our save
beat buttons aren't working
what do we do to mess up the rest of
this
collide point event.pause
i think we don't want these all to be
lifts because uh technically they're in
the same
spots let's see if that solves it i
think that's causing us strife
let's check that out
load beat
entry rectangle is not defined
something strange is happening
load beat
we need to check out why entry rectangle
is not defined it's coming from save
menu
oh well yeah entry rectangle is not
going to be defined
because uh
if save menu is not true then there's no
rect
so let's come down to the rectangles
like this one
and let's just add something here that's
if
save menu
and then we'll put all of this inside of
it
and i think we'll want the same thing
for
these three because they're loading only
so we'll say
if load
menu
so we do need to distinguish that we
don't want to check for anything with
these three buttons if that is not true
and then hopefully that'll take care of
it so if we load in
saving button is not defined but why do
you care i thought i have you
checked out so you don't care
oh we want all of this inside the same
if save menu there we go let's try that
load beat tom and clap
there it
is clear the beat load in generic rock
beat let's load it in
yeah that's hardcore
all right let's just make it 12
and uh let's do something stupid i don't
know it doesn't matter
let's try to save this as
longer beat let's save it let's see if
we can load in longer beat yeah i'll go
ahead and clear this i'll load in the
generic rock beat
i'll load
in the generic rock beat okay
i'll clear it out and i'll see if i can
load in the longer beat and it makes it
12. all right so we have the ability to
turn off individual channels we have the
ad ability to play and pause we have the
ability to edit while something's active
or inactive
we have the ability to change how many
beats are in the loop we have the
ability to save beats we have the
ability to load beats we have the
ability to clear the board this is a
really cool app i had a ton of fun
building it obviously it's a challenging
tutorial i know it's been a really long
time so if you stuck it out the whole
time i hope you're enjoying it if you
have any questions about things we
didn't cover or you'd like to see
expanded upon or you tried this yourself
and you're running into snags just let
me know about in the comments below i'll
get back to you as soon as i can i hope
you enjoyed it if you did please leave a
like on the video subscribe to my
channel it helps me out a ton and i post
tons of great content just like this
every week so without any further ado
good luck with your projects and thanks
for watching take it easy until next
time bye